>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D. C.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Good morning.
Good morning, ladies and gentlemen.
And welcome to the African
and Malaysian division
of the Library of congress.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb,
chief of the division.
And I'm delighted to see you here
today for this exciting symposium
on the ancient city of Tyre.
I want first to thank Dr. Maha
Chalabi, the founder and president
of the International Association
to Save Tyre, for her proposal
to hold this conference at
the Library of Congress.
I want to thank Congressman
Charles Boustany
who supported this initiative
from the start to finish.
I also want to recognize all
those who have worked tirelessly
for the past year to make this event
possible, including the entire board
of the American Committee for Tyre
and its president Ambassador
Killion.
His wife is here to represent him
and to represent the association.
I want to thank Randa Hudome
of Hudome International.
I want to thank Rim Chalabi who's
been an incredible force behind
this event.
And the honorable Esther
Coopersmith, the goodwill ambassador
to UNESCO, who has opened
her home for us to meet.
Jan Jiplan [spelling assumed], who
created a buzz around this event
with a great media event at the
National Press Club in February.
And many others.
And of course I want to thank my
own division for all they have done.
They have been fantastic.
So have our media office.
So have our videotaping
office and everybody else.
When Dr. Maha Chalabi
approached me over a year ago
about holding a conference at the
library on Tyre, I was thrilled.
It had been one of my goals while
at the library to do a series
of symposia on ancient
cities of the near east.
So what better place to
start than with Tyre?
One of the oldest cities in the
world that is still inhabited
and perhaps still inhabited
by some of the descendants
of the original denizens.
What better place to start than
with a Phoenician civilization
that gave the world its
first phonetic alphabet,
without which there would be no
books, there would be no libraries.
At least not in the
form that we know today.
Let me conclude with a quote from
the introduction to the catalog
of the most important exhibition
on Phoenicians ever held.
It was held in the Palazzo
Grassi Museum in Venice in 1988.
This quote could apply
to our symposium today.
The conveners of the conference
wrote, "It is not our intention
to present merely documentary
evidence and with that carry
out a work of diffusion and
burgeoning of knowledge.
We believe that reproposing
the splendor
of this distant civilization
means a return to the continuity
of a culture which is
deeply Mediterranean.
Certainly civilization is progress.
It is continual modification,
permanent advancement.
But we cannot act in the present
without an awareness of our roots
that penetrate deeply
into the past."
And now, to welcome you to
welcome you to the Library
of Congress is our chief
of staff Robert Newlen.
Robert Newlen was appointed chief
of staff on December 14th, 2014.
In this capacity he has
led library-wide programs
in management responsibilities
and also oversees the offices
of communications, congressional
relations, development,
the office of the chief
financial officer, contracts,
grant management, general counsel
and special events
and public programs.
Robert Newlen joined the
library in November, 1975.
In more than 39 years at the
institution he has served
in a wide range of areas and roles.
He assumed the position of
assistant law librarian 2010 and as
such he oversaw the
collection, development, research
and reference services and outreach
to the law library's
diverse constituency.
He also managed the law
library's development
and fundraising initiatives.
And last year oversaw the
library's Magna Carta exhibition
and its related events.
Princess Ann participated
in these events.
And Robert really did a
fantastic, fantastic job.
I don't want to go any further.
I want you to hear from Robert.
So thank you again.
Thank you, Robert.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert Newlen: Thank you,
Mary-Jane, and good morning.
And on behalf of the Librarian
of Congress, James H. Billington,
it's my pleasure to welcome
you to the Library of Congress.
I have the honor and privilege of
serving as chief of staff here.
When Mary-Jane mentioned the
date, I started in December 2014.
I thought she almost said 1914.
[ Laughter ]
I'm old, but not that old.
So I'm delighted to see
so many people here today
for this historic symposium
on the ancient city of Tyre.
Although the library has
sponsored innumerable conferences
over the years, it's
my understanding
that this is the first
conference that has been held
on the Phoenicians and the
ancient cities they founded
on the Mediterranean.
So we have a historic moment here.
For this initiative I would
like to join Mary-Jane
in thanking the American Committee
for Tyre, the Tyre Foundation
and Dr. Maha Chalabi, the founder
of the International
Association to Save Tyre.
I'd also like to thank the
honorable Charles Boustany,
Jr. for his support
of the symposium.
Ambassador David Killion,
the president and chairman
of the American Committee for Tyre.
And the honorable Esther Coopersmith
who is an honorary chair as well
as one of the original
founders of the committee.
And among our very treasures
here in the Library of Congress,
none is greater than Mary-Jane
Deeb, the chief of the African
and Middle East Division.
[ Applause ]
Thank you, Mary-Jane for
your vision and leadership.
It's most fitting that we hold this
conference in the northeast pavilion
of the Thomas Jefferson building.
As you entered the African and
Middle Eastern reading room
of the library, I hope you
noticed that Tyre is inscribed
above the very decorative door.
Carthage, another Phoenician
city, appears on its left as well.
So it's very fitting that
the founders and creators
of the library were very much
aware of the ancient civilizations
of the near east and had
the names and symbols
of these civilizations fixed
to the walls and ceilings
of this great Jefferson building.
So I'm going to end and just
wish you a very enjoyable day.
As we hear from a whole
range of celebrated scholars.
And we thank all of the scholars
for their participation today.
I would now like to
introduce our next speaker,
the distinguished member from
the third district of Louisiana,
Representative Charles
Boustany, Jr. Again, Congressman,
we're enormously grateful
to you for your support.
And I had the privilege
of just speaking briefly
with a congressman this
morning about his ancestors
and how they came to
America from Lebanon.
And it's a fascinating story
and I hope we'll hear more
about it in the future.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Charles Boustany, Jr.:
Well thank you, Robert.
And good morning to all of you.
Thank you, Mary-Jane, for the
great work you're doing here
at the library.
And I want to thank all
who have been involved
in putting this very
important symposium together.
It's so relevant to
what's happening today.
It's so important for us to
reflect back on important history
and the lessons to be learned.
I come here with a
little bit of humility
because there's tremendous
expertise in this room
and in this very important room.
In a section of the library
which is an incredible repository
of knowledge that cannot
be replaced anywhere.
So this is a fitting place to
hold this type of symposium.
And again, this is daunting just
for me to stand here in front of you
and offer a few humble remarks.
Let me just start by saying I've
been a longtime reader of history.
I love history.
And this came about because of my
grandfather who at the ripe old age
of 15 arrived alone from
Lebanon, trying to find his sister
in the state of Louisiana
who married someone here.
I don't know how she ended up
in Louisiana to begin with.
We need to find that out.
But I learned a lot
from my grandfather,
who went from having nothing when he
arrived to becoming very successful
in business and banking and
giving me, two generations later,
this tremendous opportunity
to stand before you.
First as a very successful
cardiac surgeon and now
with a career in public office.
And I owe so much to him.
But one of the most important
things he told me and imbued
in me was not only a love of
reading and reading history.
But he taught me about my heritage.
I might not have known.
And the first time I ever heard
about the Phoenicians was sitting
on the lap of my grandfather
when I was a young child.
And his intense sense
of pride was amazing.
And I remember he told me
after the first World War,
he went back to Lebanon
to find his mother.
His father had passed
away in the interim time.
He found his brother who was
on the verge of starvation.
And this is just one of many, many
stories I'm sure have been repeated
across America with
a Lebanese diaspora.
But when you reflect on the Lebanese
diaspora, it's quite amazing.
Because there are people
all across this country
who have reached the pinnacle of
their professions or chosen line
of work, whether it's the arts,
sciences, or professions in medicine
and law, education and so forth.
It's quite amazing.
And I wasn't really aware
of this until I actually got
into public office and began to meet
so many across this great country.
But my grandfather
taught me about history.
And that love of history
never went away.
And I embarked on reading
and studying ancient
Mediterranean history.
And fast forward, I took a course
on ancient civilizations in college.
And there was a history
professor there, long deceased,
who had a profound impact on me
despite all my education science.
This one class furthered
my love of history,
took it to a different level
for me and taught me one thing
that I have never forgotten,
that history is a living thing.
It's not old dates and
artifacts that have gone away
and they're collecting dust.
History is living.
It affects us today.
And I think that is
incredibly relevant.
That's why this symposium
is so important.
Just take for a moment, I'll give
you just a few more reflections
on that before I close.
First of all, we all know what's
happening across the Middle East
with the tremendous chaos
and the difficulties,
much of it playing out in Lebanon.
Well, antiquity is being
destroyed across the world
as a result of some of this.
This is something that's not getting
the kind of attention it needs.
And hopefully this symposium with
publicity surrounding it will put
that into the public domain.
We are having conversations
about that in Congress.
But it's so important to
preserve these antiquities
because they have impact
on us today.
Let me just reflect for just a
moment on the city-state of Tyre
and what is now Lebanon but was
a Phoenician empire in days past.
Tyre is regarded as the greatest
maritime trading civilization
in the world.
And you all know the stories about
how the alphabet and so forth.
Trade is critically important
and it's relevant today.
This is a heated debate we're
having in Congress today
on whether America will embark
on a very aggressive trade policy
and provide that kind of
leadership to bring us together
through commercial relationships.
I think an avenue for peace.
Or will we back away from
trade, become more isolationist
in our own views and basically give
up American leadership globally?
So what happened in ancient
civilization when the understanding
of the importance of trade was
not quite so well understood,
the creativity of the Phoenician
civilization was quite amazing.
And it was centered upon Tyre.
So we have a lot to learn
by studying the history,
learning from the mistakes
that were made,
but also the great
advances that were made.
So I want to thank you all
for putting this together.
It's a very important symposium.
I wish I could spend
the entire day with you.
I've got duties calling at 10:00.
But thank you for your insights.
Thank you for your willingness
to put this together.
And I look forward to learning
a whole lot more from all of you
as you embark further on making
this information public knowledge.
Thank you very much.
It's great to be with you.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
Before I go any further,
I would like to recognize
the two ambassadors
of the two parts of
the Phoenician world.
The ambassador of Lebanon,
Ambassador Shadig [assumed
spelling] is with us.
So thank you very much
for being here.
And then the colleague
ambassador of Tunisia.
[ Applause ]
So we are delighted to have
them both here, our two worlds.
So now we are going to have a very
special person, Ms. Rodi Kratsa,
who is the president of the
Konstantinos Karamanlis Institute
for Democracy in Greece, and
the former vice president
of the European parliament.
Rodi Kratsa started sociology
at the University of Geneva
and continued her post-graduate
studies at the Institute
of European Studies of
the same university.
She has rich experience and
long tenure in European politics
and in Euro-Mediterranean relations.
She represented the European
parliament in high-level summits
and ministerial conferences
worldwide.
She is a member of the European
parliament committee on economic
and monetary affairs, on
the committee of employment
and social affairs,
and other committees.
Rodi Kratsa has always been very
active at the international level.
She has worked systematically
for the deepening of EU relations
with significant areas of the world.
Especially the caucuses
and the south shores
of the Mediterranean
and the Middle East.
Shh. You have to lower your
voices because of the echo.
You see, we can hear
everything here.
So I would like to
invite her to address us.
And thank you, Ms.
Kratsa, for being with us.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Rodi Kratsa: Thank you
very much for the kind words.
Excellencies, honorable members
of Congress, Mrs. President
of the Tyre Foundation,
ambassadors, Mr. Vice President
of the American Committee for Tyre.
We are friends of Tyre,
ladies and gentlemen.
It is with great pleasure and
honor that I am participating
in this symposium dedicated to Tyre.
In an atmosphere from the legacy
of the historic metropolis
of Phoenicians.
As an active member of
Tyre Foundation I believe
that it is an excellent privilege
and important opportunity to share
with this distinguished American
and international audience all
the concerns and commitments
for the protection of
the cultural heritage
and the highlights of
the legacy of Tyre.
For this reason I would like
first of all to thank those
of you responsible for the
Library of Congress and the members
of the American Committee for
Tyre who give us this possibility.
I'm sure that the symposium will
provide us valuable information
for the rich history of
Tyre, the role that it played
in the international community
of that period, the Mediterranean
and the near coast of the Atlantic.
We become more aware of the
importance which the world carried
for ancient people for
the next generations.
And we will also understand
that the challenges are
for the conservation
of the civilization.
The last few years we have become
witnesses to extreme violence,
mainly for interim classes
and obscurities mentalities
with destructive inconsideration
for monuments
and symbols of world heritage.
There could be other destructive
actions in cases of occupation
or even during periods of
peace due to indifference,
ignorance or natural disasters.
We can also recall where
there has been destruction
of religious monuments which
belonged to minorities.
There has been of course legal
instruments for the protection
of cultural assets, such
as the NESCO engagement,
or the Hague Convention
and its protocols.
As well as the decisions
for the security consul
of the United Nations for
emergency cases of foreign conflict.
The most important issue though is
the prevention of the destruction
and the activation of
the domestic population
and the politician actors.
I know that the American
society shares this political
and moral globalist possibility.
I have opportunity to collaborate
with the American Congressmen
and the American institutions
in this area as vice president
of the European Parliament.
I feel obligation to mention
that already from April 1863,
President Lincoln announced the
general directive for the protection
of cultural assets of war zones.
Later on, on April
1935 in Washington,
there was signed the Convention
for the Protection of Artistic
and Scientific Institutions
and Historic Monuments.
But it also determined
about the cases
of protection for armed conflict.
This addition interprets
sensitivity and the active interest
for the world heritage,
in particular for the unique
history for Tyre and Lebanon.
From today's symposium we will
also ascertain the inspiration
that the heritage could give us
for modern creative projects.
This is another dimension
of the fantastic roles
of the Tyre Foundation
and the international
association to save Tyre.
Here I would like to congratulate
the president and the founder,
my friend Dr. Maha
El-Khalil Chalabi.
As well as the partners and
members of the foundation
of that association
for their commitment,
their creativity and
their efficiency.
We mentioned further on the labels
of the symposium those projects
such as the institute, the
library and the Virtual Museum
for Canaanite, Phoenician
and Punic Cities in Beirut.
The Lisa Dedoun Prize, the
Hangukuk village in Tyre.
The revival and the reclamation
of the ancient civilization
of the Phoenicians
contribute to the radiance
of Tyre and Lebanon in general.
This is also very important to
mention the league of Canaanite,
Phoenician and Punic Cities
which is constituted of islands
and cities in the Mediterranean.
Stations in the role of Phoenicians.
Greece, my country.
A country with a great
naval tradition civilization
with historic interaction
with the Phoenicians.
Participates actively
and we are in the process
to create the Greek committee for
the enforcement of these activities.
These initiatives offer many
opportunities for research
into the past, but also dialogue,
exchanges and collaborations
for common development
projects of mutual interest.
In conclusion, ladies and
gentlemen, I would like to share
with you my feelings that today
we will have an exceptional day
for the exceptional Tyre.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
And now we are going
to have really the
star of this event.
Dr. Maha Chalabi is the initiator.
She is the mover and shaker, not
only in Washington but in Paris,
in London, in Lebanon and
everywhere she has been.
She is the person who
has put Tyre once again
on the map historically
and culturally.
A native of Tyre in south Lebanon,
Dr. Maha Chalabi grew up surrounded
by the prestigious vestiges
of this ancient city
on which eight successive
civilizations have laid
their imprint.
For almost 30 years, Maha
Chalabi has dedicated herself
to making Tyre better known.
And I have to tell you she has
succeeded and succeeded very well.
She graduated with a degree in
political science from the faculty
of [inaudible] University in Beirut.
And earned her doctorate in
history from the Sorbonne.
Starting in the 1970's, she
worked hard to get Tyre recognized
as a world heritage site in
order to ensure its protection.
Soon thereafter, starting in '78,
UNESCO recognized the necessity
of civ guarding the whole
of the archaeological site
of Tyre and its surroundings.
She received those recognitions by
the United Nations Security Council,
the European Parliament, the
American Senate, the House of Lords,
the World Federation of Twin Towns
followed and all unanimously agreed
to declare Tyre a world
heritage site.
Strengthened in her resolve
by this support emanating
from the world's highest
political organizations,
Maha Chalabi created the
International Association
to Save Tyre.
Which assembled eminent
personalities from the worlds
of culture and science, all
deeply concerned about the future
of this ancient metropolis.
On the 5th of May, 1980
during the Day of Tyre,
held at UNESCO's Paris headquarters,
the International Association
to Save Tyre received
official recognition.
And Maha Chalabi was
elected secretary general.
In February 1986 the French
president awarded Maha the [French
term], a medal for
exceptional services.
In March 1986, the French minister
of culture named her [French term].
In 1988 the Lebanese
president named her officer
of the Natural Order of the Cedar.
There is much, much more to
say about this fantastic lady.
But I would like her
to say a few words.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Maha Chalabi: My
dear distinguished audience,
Mr. Ambassador of Lebanon,
Mr. Ambassador
of Tunisia, ladies and gentlemen.
It's a great honor that we
launch the memorial day for Tyre.
Paying tribute to this very
old city within the premises
of the eminent cultural
monument, the Library of Congress.
Culture has always been a solid
bond between Lebanon and the US.
With this series of
Lebanese-American writers and poets
from Ameen Rihani, Ria
Aboulmadi [assumed spelling],
Michael Nami [assumed spelling],
and the famous Gibran Khalil Gibran.
Today we go further
back into the past
to celebrate the Phoenician
city of Tyre.
It's also with great delight that
we will comb the broad spectrum
of distinguished friends who came
from around the world to take part
in this glorious meeting celebrating
Tyre, the queen of the seas,
the ship of perfect beauty and
the mother of civilizations.
Some might wonder if it's
still timely to speak
about this Phoenician city.
What can we add to all
that has been related
since ancient times to present day?
Despite the significance of what
has been written and published,
we are confident that a
lot is yet to be revealed.
All the discoveries remain
below what the future may unveil
about the history of this
city-state that has led the basis
of faithful globalization,
connecting ports and cities
of the ancient world
around the Mediterranean.
Seeking for, establishing
a faithful exchange.
Tyre was also the homeland of
great scholars who left their marks
on the human past and contributed
to its progress at a time
when the ancient world
was still primitive.
Eminent philosophers
like Thales, Pythagoras
and [inaudible] contributed
to the glory of Tyre.
Kingdom of great kings and
builders like Hiram and Hiram Abiff.
Motherland of Cadmous,
Elissa and Ropa.
Tyre has yet to unveil its
countless hidden treasures.
Scientists are still monitoring
recent archaeological excavations
which promise to disclose
more wonders.
Here in the new world, the Library
of Congress recognized a long
time ago the prominence of Tyre
and its role in the development
of human civilization.
It's by no coincidence that the name
of Tyre tops the main
door of this hall.
Today knowledge and
wisdom take its roots
from the glorious ancient world
and Tyre was one of its pillars.
It's a great honor for us people
of Phoenician descent,
a source of noble pride.
Our gathering on this very day,
dedicated to Tyre within the Library
of Congress would not
have been possible
without the concerted efforts
of the head administrator
of this institute, Mr. James
Billington, the librarian.
And Mrs. Mary-Jane Deeb, head of the
African and Middle East division.
Our appreciate goes also to
all present, loyal speakers
who are supporting our action
by their research and studies.
You are the real engine
for moving forward.
Honorable Congressman Charles
Boustany, we are very grateful
for his tremendous support,
sponsorship and commitment
to give Tyre such a memorable day.
And finally, I wish to
thank all the participants
for their great work and dedication.
You are the real custodians
of culture
and committed promoters
of knowledge.
God bless you.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: And you have
heard really from the person
who has made all this possible.
And now last but not least I would
like to introduce Richard Arndt.
Richard Arndt has a
bio which is so long
that it was very difficult
for me to cut it down.
But anyway, I'll try briefly
to say he has been the chair
of the US Committee
for the Preservation
of Ancient Tyre from 2000-2014.
He is the vice president, co-chair,
advisory council of
Americans for UNESCO.
He's the vice president of
the Fullbright Association.
He's the founding editor of the
journal Prospects and Retrospects.
He is the chair of a
five-nation selection committee
for the Fullbright Prize for
international understanding.
He is the founding chair
of the Lois Roth Endowment.
He has been a member of
the steering committee
for Fullbright legacy lecture
trips and professorships
at Pembroke College at Oxford.
He has been the chair
of the National Peace
Foundation between '92 and '95.
And the co-chair of the
Peace Builder Award.
He has also been the advisor of
the Toda Institute for Global Peace
and Policy Research, the
East-West Center in Hawaii.
Over and above this he has also
had a long and successful career
in the US foreign service where
he worked between '61 and '85
with the United States Information
Agency and the Department of State
in Washington, D.C. He also served
in the Department of State Bureau
of Education and Cultural Affairs
where he was deputy
director for Latin America.
But he has served at the American
embassies in France, Italy, Iran,
Sri Lanka, Lebanon among others.
So I would like to invite him
to round up this first panel.
[ Applause ]
>> Richard Arndt: We're
running out of time.
I brought some notes here, but
I don't think I'll read them.
As Mary-Jane has told you,
I've led a very peculiar life,
scattered all over the place.
But my original job was to greet
you and to welcome you on behalf
of the American committee, which
I have been asked to re-chair
in the absence of Ambassador
David Killion who is somewhere
between Korea and Los Angeles
at this very moment on a plane
which is heading this way.
And we hope he'll be there
in time for dinner tonight.
But that's the diplomatic
life for you.
The thing that I wanted to reflect
on very quickly, very quickly,
because we have lots of
interesting things to do,
is that we are living today
in the presence of one
of the great mansions
of the American mind.
This house here, as it were,
was founded by Thomas Jefferson
I suppose among others.
And there's another one down
the street which was founded
by an Englishman named
Smithson and two professors
from Princeton named
Henry and Spencer Baird.
And these two mansions of American
intellect and mind sit here
on the mall in a town
in which the use
of mind is largely
turned to other pursuits.
[ Laughter ]
And the result being that questions
like Tyre often get
lost in the melee.
In contrast, for example, to
1943 when a delegation came
to President Roosevelt and said,
"You're going to invade Europe.
You've got to save the monuments."
And the so the monumentsmen,
and you've all see I
suppose the film now,
which is one tiny little fingernail
about what the monumentsmen actually
did, went along with the troops.
And did what they could to preserve,
to maintain, to repair in some cases
and to restore to their
rightful owners some of the works
that had been disrupted by war.
Surely the same thing is
happening in the Middle East now.
The war that is raging makes
almost anything serious impossible.
And yet civilized people --
and I believe we're all
that in this room --
should get together to do something
in order to save Tyre for posterity.
Now I did actually bring
this book only to show you
that someone is doing
something about it.
This is the catalog.
I can hardly lift it.
It's the catalog of the exhibit
called Assyria to Iberia.
That's just because
it rhymed you see.
Which took place at the Metropolitan
Museum this winter and spring.
It was an astonishing show.
Something like 130 museums
from around the world all pooled
their things together to talk
about the Hittites and the Meads
and all these strange people
that we all know about.
But we don't quite
remember where they belong.
But the Phoenicians were right there
at the bottom all the way through.
You open this book, you look and
page after page there is Phoenicia.
There is Tyre.
There is Sour, Tyre
and Sidon and so forth.
And so it's all there and
yet it hasn't been done.
There has to be a book, maybe
not quite as thick as this one,
but at least a serious book
about Tyre one of these days.
And I would hope that
after the publication
that much emerged from
this symposium.
And by the way, which
should probably be prefaced
by that remarkable introduction
that Ambassador Shadig made
last night at the embassy.
Which was full of interesting
insights and new ways
of looking at the Tyre problem.
So it's with great hope that in the
mansions of mind and America and all
over Europe -- I count six
or seven different countries
who have sent scholars
to this symposium.
Whereas in the old days we used to
fight with the French all the time.
Now we're friends with the French.
We work together on everything.
Including in this show.
So let us work hard to see
what we can do as human beings,
as civilized people for the
future of the world insofar
as that little pocket of water,
rocks and earth called Tyre is able
to be saved for humanity.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: So
now we've concluded
with our introductory panel.
I thank you very much.
Let's give them a hand.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: So the
first panel is entitled Cradle
of Civilization.
And we will begin with
Dr. Leila Badre.
Dr. Leila Badre is the director
of the archaeological museum
at the American University
of Beirut.
She holds a doctorate from
the University Paris Sorbonne.
She has excavated numerous
sites in Lebanon and Syria,
as well as in Dubai, Jamaya in
'69-70 and in Yemen as well.
She has directed the
archaeological work in Tell Kazel,
Syria between '85 and 2010.
And in Tyre in 2012.
She considers her major achievement,
despite all these incredible
achievements,
she considers her major achievement
to be the total renovation
of the American University
of Beirut's museum in 2006.
And also the creation
of a new crypt museum
at the St. George cathedral
in Lebanon.
She is the founder of the Friends
of the AUB Museum and the founder
of the Lebanese National Committee
for the International
Council of Museums.
She's also the founding member
of the Lebanese National
Heritage Association.
So Dr. Leila Badre.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Leila Badre: I'm
very honored to speak
in this prestigious institution,
the Library of Congress.
Thank you, Maha, for
inviting me here.
The subject of my presentation is
the first Phoenician temple in Tyre,
which we have recently
excavated in Tyre.
By launching a new excavation
project in Tyre, the main objective
of the American University of
Beirut museum team was first
to reach the Phoenician levels of
the famous Phoenician city of Tyre.
The second target was to discover
the assumed temple whose possible
location was mentioned
to us by Mr. Badouwi,
the director of antiquities in Tyre.
The early temples of
Tyre have been mentioned
in several historical sources.
To mention but a couple,
first the legend of Karat
from the 14th century when King
Karat stopped building his district
at the shrine of [inaudible]
of Tyre.
This temple was probably
located on the mainland.
Second, Hiram's builders in the
5th century BC gave a detailed
description of the temple
of Heracles, the main temple
of Tyre which had two columns.
One of gold and one of emerald.
But the most important
iconographic source where the city
of Tyre is presented in a
sculpture believed from the palace
of Sennacherib in Nineveh,
dated to 690 BC.
A temple, probably that of
Melkar is depicted above the port
with two free-standing columns as
you see it indicated by the arrow.
The site which we selected
to excavate is located
on the island of Phoenician Tyre.
It's a known fact that ancient
Tyre was originally a rocky island,
hence it's Phoenician name, Sour.
Alexander the Great joined it
later to the mainland by a causeway
over which sand deposits
accumulated through the years,
forming an artificial isthmus.
This island appears now as a
peninsula stretching out to the sea.
What did our site of sector seven
look like before the investigation?
After the departure of Emir
Shihab from Tyre at the break
of the Lebanese War in 1975, the
sector seven which is located
within the Phoenician island
of Tyre had been abandoned
for nearly 40 years.
The consequence of this
abandonment resulted in the growing
of a four-meter high reed forest
which covered the entire area
to be investigated by
the AUB museum team.
To our great surprise, some
ancient walls began to appear.
But the greater surprise was that
the site had already been excavated
by Emir Shihab some 40 years ago
without anyone knowing about it.
Not a single report or
archive were available
to indicate this earlier discovery.
Yet in the process of my research
I discovered the following lines
written by Shihab in 1979
of the first Phoenician
and Punic Congress in Rome.
He mentioned among other results
of his excavations in Tyre
in 1973 a large Phoenician monument
with a 10-meter long wall
that we will show later.
It's obvious that Emir Shihab
did not recognize then the nature
of this vast monument
as he mentioned it.
Our luck was that this
monument clearly refers
to the temple we were
about to excavate.
Our task was therefore
to rediscover the site
and to complete Shihab's
excavation in view
of analyzing this important
monument, documenting it,
interpreting its function
and attempting
to determine its historical
chronology.
The temple in sector seven was
located under the residential area
of the classical period, which
extended further to the northwest.
What did we actually discover?
From the first two weeks and
after sketching a working plan
of the archaeological remains, we
could already assume that we were
in front of a temple due to the
presence of a massive construction
which could clearly and
yet tentatively be
identified as a podium.
The temple has a rectangular shape,
21 meters long and 6.50 meters wide.
Its axis is oriented
northwest/southeast.
Several structures were
found within the temple.
First of all, the podium which
is two meter high structure.
It consists of a foundation
course, surrounded by three courses
of very large blocks
in hard sandstone.
The setting follows the structure
and [inaudible] which is well-known
in the Phoenician architecture.
The blocks of this podium can
be compared in size to those
of the podium of the Eshmun temple
that you can see on the lower photo.
Which are close in length to ours
but are double in width and height
with a weight of two
tons and a half.
Those of Eshmun.
The Eshmun temple is a
gigantic one by its size.
It is inspired by the
Babylonian Ziggurat.
It is 22 meters high, but its
podium alone has been preserved.
None of the temple
has been preserved.
Our Tyre temple blocks were
constructed in the nearby quarries
which are partly under
the seawater today.
Two sings that are
shown on the podium.
One letter is M like
the McDonald M, and Z,
were incised on the upper block.
These are probably the
signatures of the masons
which were used for
accounting purpose.
Similar signs have been identified
on a contemporary documented
building in Byblos.
On top of the podium,
an altar was placed.
It is a very large monolithic
single-stone slab made
out of marine limestone.
This altar presents a wavy surface
which may suggest hypothetically
that it was used intentionally
in order to make the flowing
of the sacrificial blood possible.
A massive structure
located on the eastern end
of the temple is built opposite and
symmetrical to the podium you see
on the massive structure.
And the podium on the upper part.
One could imagine that this
structure could have been the
foundation of a massive
structure, maybe a tower.
And that this tower may have
had a niche in which the deity
of the temple would have been
placed facing the podium.
This was the case in
many oriental temples.
The plan of the temple is
indicated by a large rectangle.
The average preservation
of the walls is one course,
but sometimes six courses.
They are made out of fine sandstone
blocks nearly half size compared
to the blocks of the podium.
And this is how we could
immediately identify the podium.
Because it's totally much
bigger blocks than the walls.
The walls are generally set
in regular structure pattern
as you see in the lower photo.
The two long walls of the temple
are built against the western wall
which is the western
limit of the temple.
This view shows the inner
faade of the western wall.
Its external faade is
beautifully decorated
with a long continuous
horizontal phrase
of what we call Egyptian courses.
It consists of five
preserved courses
with finely dressed sandstone
blocks tightly set together
with very thin joints and
without any bonding material.
The same architectural decorative
Egyptian gorges are known
from the Phoenician temple in
Amrit on the coast of Syria
where it decorates the
upper part of its towers.
Similarly, at the Eshmun temple
near Sidon, the same type of blocks
with the Egyptian gorges
have been noted
by our team during a site
visit to the Eshmun temple.
Some hydraulic installations,
wells and basins which are common
in the Phoenician temples have
been found around our temple.
They testified to the important
role that water rituals played
in Phoenician therapeutic
cults as it is emphasized
in both Eshmun and Amrit temples.
This basin has four steps
that leads to its bottom.
It could have been used for
purposes in relation to the temple.
The main problem we faced was
to find the temple entrance,
which we finally found.
About the center of the
western wall we found this setup
or these structures.
The lowest platform which will
present the earliest circulation
level of the temple built with
huge blocks about one meter long.
It leads into a two-meter wide
opening with a door socket.
The width of which exists throughout
various areas of the entrance.
The middle platform is built
directly on top of the earlier one,
and it is also dotted
with a door socket.
A third paved platform entrance
was added to the two previous ones.
It is set between two
walls which were built
between the two lateral walls
of the temple and which served
as arch support for
this paved floor.
We suppose as a hypothesis that
this pavement could have extended
with a slight ramp.
You can see it on the lower picture.
Towards the east to
reach the embossed level
of the first course of the podium.
With this hypothesis it is
possible to imagine the entrance
of the temple from the west side,
not the east as it
is usually the case
in the Phoenician or
oriental temples.
This would lead directly
to the altar level in view
of the execution of the sacrifice.
A kiln is built against the
eastern faade of the podium.
Two oblique altar stands placed
in an inverted V shape
mark its doorway opening.
Black traces can be
seen on its upper part.
And gray ashes are
found near the doorway.
An important burn deposit
mixed with ashes
and small charcoal bits was
found opposite the kiln.
A small section of this deposit
was collected and sifted,
producing 17 buckets
of small animal bones.
It seems pretty obvious that
the animals of rather small
or medium size, which were
sacrificed on top of the altar,
were probably thrown directly
in the cremation kiln.
The presence of a few items found
around the temple may be considered
as offerings to the temple divinity.
Among these, one [inaudible] found
by our colleague Dr. Eddie
Curel outside the temple.
The presence of few
items may be considered
as offerings to the temple divinity.
One [inaudible], as I said, found by
Dr. Curel, two large stone anchors,
a few lamp fragments, not to
forget the burnt animal bones found
in the deposit in the
vicinity of the kiln.
All these are extra evidence that
our monument is indeed a temple.
Chronological conclusions.
As we have indicated
earlier, in the total absence
of stratigraphic records and the
lack of pottery materials found
in C2, it's rather
difficult at this stage
to draw any final chronological
conclusions.
Because most of the
pottery is mixed,
we can only draw some
post-antiquan periods, the end.
From the Persian to
the Hellenistic period.
On this basis, we may
tentatively conclude
that the temple itself
belongs to the Persian period.
This dating is enhanced by the
common architectural features
and masonry techniques which are
known from the neighboring temples
of the region, especially from the
Eshmun temple in Sidon and that
of Armit in Syria as stated earlier.
The underwater sounding [inaudible]
a group of Phoenician pottery.
This explains the large number of
iron tools that have been collected
in various points, but not in C2.
This preliminary assessment of the
pottery may hint to a continuous use
of this temple retaining its sacral
character from the Achaemenid
to the Hellenistic period and
possibly including the early phases
of the Roman occupation as well.
As it stands and with all the very
good results we have just presented,
we may conclude that our newly
rediscovered temple is the first
Phoenician temple in Tyre
and the first complete
Phoenician temple in Lebanon.
Thank you.
[ Appllause ]
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: We will now
have a presentation in French,
but we have simultaneous
translation.
And this is a presentation by
Dr. Naji Karam, an archaeologist,
former director of art
and archaeology department
of the Lebanese University.
The scientific director MCP
research institute of Lebanon.
Dr. Naji Karam holds a Ph. D in
archaeology from the Institute
of Archaeology and Human
Science University.
Former professor of the Phoenician
archaeology department and director
of art and archaeology
in the department
of the Lebanese University
second division.
He is the director of the Church
Cultural Heritage Committee
in Lebanon.
A member of the Lebanese
organization [French term].
And he is the scientific director
of the institute for research
on Canaanite, Phoenician
and Punic civilization.
So Dr. Naji Karan, if you
would like to come up.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Speaking French ]
>> So, ladies and gentlemen,
I am going to translate what
Dr. Naji Karam is going to talk
about today and he will give
you a chronological description
of the prehistory and
history of the city of Tyre.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So the history of the
city of Tyre is rare.
We do not know a lot about the city.
And Dr. Karam is going to
give us a brief description
of the various archaeological
and stratigraphic layers
that are available.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So the first phase
that he will mention is
from prehistory to history.
So we are talking about the first
phase of settlement in Tyre.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So the first phase that actually
has been proven archaeologically
to exist goes back
to the Chalcolithic period
which is around 4000 BC.
And the Lebanese University
was given
in the '70's an archaeological
find that dates to that period.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So a site known as [French name]
proves this archaeological find
which is a pottery
remain, pottery base.
And he will describe it for us.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So the second phase
is the bronze age period,
the early bronze age period.
Which fits together with the
ancient Greek historian Herodotus
and it dates back to
the year 2750 BC.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So an archeological
trench was dug
that reveals these various phases
from the 1970's that goes back
to the third millennium BC.
[ Speaking French ]
>> In that period, Tyre begins
to develop its urban character
and it has two main ports, an
Egyptian one and a Phoenician one.
[ Speaking French ]
>> There is an inscription in
Ebla in Syria in the site known
as [French name] and it
dates to the year 2300 BC.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So the next phase
that we're moving
to is the middle bronze
age, the new bronze age.
Which indicates that in the second
millennium BC there was an invasion
of Amorites in Tyre.
Which indicated that
the city was plundered
and attacked heavily
by the Amorites.
[ Speaking French ]
>> After the departure of the
Amorites, the city of Tyre
and especially the port goes through
a peaceful phase of existence.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So the third phase
is the late bronze age,
which is in the 15th century BC.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So during that period in the 15th
century we have an Egyptian invasion
that begins and several phases of it
and they last for several centuries.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So during this phase there is
evidence of a continuous change
in the life of Tyre between
a peaceful and a war phase.
And in [French name] there is
evidence on tablets of the life
of the correspondence that
took place between Tyre
and this other city in Syria.
[ Speaking French ]
>> The next phase is the early iron
age which is right at the beginning
of the invasion of the sea
people in the year 1200 BC.
[ Speaking French ]
>> The local people will begin
to develop an incredible economy
and this would be the golden
age of the Phoenicians.
[ Speaking French ]
>> The dominance of Tyre in the
year 1000 BC rises to such a degree
that it expands towards Sidon and
there's a fusion between the cities
and Tyre dominates the
coast in that region.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So we move towards the 7th
century where there is an invasion
on [French name] on Tyre
with remains in Tyre itself.
[ Speaking French ]
>> And then we have the
Persians who invade the region
and invade Tyre in
the 6th century BC.
And leave their traces
all the way down to Egypt.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So we move towards the Greek
period, the 5th century BC,
the 4th century BC until we reach
the phase of Alexander the Great,
who besieged the city of six
months and it took him six months
to be able to take
Tyre, to take the city.
[ Speaking French ]
>> And then we move
towards the Roman period
where Tyre becomes very
prosperous with the Pax Ramona.
And during that phase Tyre
adopts urban characteristics
of a Roman city, including
a hippodrome, an aqua duct,
theater and so on and so forth.
[ Speaking French ]
>> And we move then to
the early medieval phase
to the Byzantine phase, where the
economy of Tyre continues to rise.
And it becomes a very important
port for the city of Damascus
and there's a very strong
connection between both cities.
[ Speaking French ]
>> During the Crusader Period,
we have an increase in the rise
of the prosperity of Tyre and there
are 93 villages surrounding the city
and there is a Byzantine
church that was built there.
And the port itself becomes a
very important strategic location
for the crusaders in communication
with their original homeland.
[ Speaking French ]
>> And by the end of the
Crusader Period, in the year 1291,
we have the expelling of
the crusaders and arrival
of the Arabs, who take
over the city.
And the city goes down
in liturgy and decay.
[ Speaking French ]
>> And so we continue
all the way 700 years
in time towards the 20th
century and we would
like to mention Earnest
Renol in the 1860's
who described the city has having
had a very prosperous past,
but for some reason it has
completely fallen into decay.
[ Speaking French ]
>> And so in the -- could
you repeat the year please?
1943 with the independence, Tyre
begins to appear once again.
And a focus on the history
is taken into action.
[ Speaking French ]
>> Tyre requires urgent and a lot of
attention in order to take its place
in its history and to be
given the right degree
of importance that it deserves.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
Thank you very much.
And thank you for the translation.
That was spontaneous and wonderful.
So we really appreciate
your help, Aliya.
And now we move to
our third speaker,
Dr. Francoise Briquel Chatonnet,
research director at
the [French name].
She's a deputy director
of the Eastern Mediterranean
Laboratory in Paris.
She works on the Phoenician
history in the first millennium BC
and on the country of
eastern Christians.
She's a member in the
[French name] in Paris.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Francoise Briquel
Chatonnet: Hello.
First allow me to thank everyone.
I am very honored to be here.
I'm very pleased.
And so I want to thank everyone
either in the Tyre committee or here
in the library who have
made this event possible.
Speaking of the Phoenician
African diffusion that I was asked
to do is a huge subject that could
well have occupied the whole day.
So I will only be able to give a
few insights on this phenomenon.
The diffusion of the
Phoenicians is well known.
We are used to speaking
of the Phoenicians
as the inventers of the alphabet.
The subject of this
naturally takes place
in a series of talks about Tyre.
But I need first to give some
details on how I see this issue.
The alphabetic system was invented
in the northwest [inaudible]
somewhere between Egypt
and [inaudible] in the middle
of the second millennium BC.
The exact place, time
and circumstances are still
objectively questioned.
But anyway, it is a period before
what we call Phoenician engineering.
And in the span of
time and evolution,
took place before we can call
the oldest properly Phoenician
inscription, that is the
royal inscription of Byblos.
One is that of Elabal.
It's a good representation.
You have the Phoenician
inscription around the [inaudible].
Here I will use this inscription as
a starting point and I will not take
into account the diffusion
of the alphabetic script
before the first millennium BC.
That is for example south Arabian
branch of the alphabet tree.
The second point I wanted
to stress is the meaning
and purpose of this diffusion.
And of the form it took.
What is clear is that purpose
of the inventor or inventors
of the alphabet was to conduct
local exchange without translation
and convey local myth and literature
in their own language and script.
In a region where Egyptian
and Acadian languages
and scripts had been
used for centuries,
it was a question of identity.
Which was the origin of
the invention and use
of the alphabetic script.
Language as the expression
of a culture.
But also of a collective
identity of a group.
The diffusion of the
Phoenician alphabet witnesses the
same phenomenon.
It can be interpreted in terms
of promotion of identities,
but also of meeting of cultures.
It is this phenomenon that I will
illustrate through three issues.
First, diffusion of Phoenician
writing outside Phoenicia.
Second the question of
bilingualism and bigraphism,
writing with two scripts.
And then the birth of
new alphabets stemming
from the Phoenician alphabet.
So first, diffusion of Phoenician
writing outside Phoenicia.
When speaking of the expansion
of the Phoenician world,
people only think of
the Mediterranean area.
But this expansion went all around
Phoenicia and it can be illustrated
with these inscriptions made
by Phoenicians or by others.
And my first example will be
this inscription in Gingerly
from the 9th century
in the Luwian world.
A local king.
So it's south of modern Turkey.
A local king of the
culture [inaudible] culture.
And the local king with
the Luwian [inaudible].
It's a witness of the adoption of
the Phoenician language and script.
The inscription is in Phoenician
language and Phoenician script.
Probably for questions of prestige.
A local language in script existed
and we will see it,
but was not used there.
So we are still wondering why this
king did write in Phoenician and not
in his local language and script.
A totally different
example is this seal
with Phoenician --
as shown by his name.
And this seal was found
in Khorsabad, Assyria.
It shows the presence of
a Phoenician individual
of very high rank in
society having his own seal.
It was found underneath a
[inaudible] in Khorsabad.
And was probably not lost
accidentally but put intentionally
as a trace of the presence
of the owner.
So here it's really
Phoenician script done
by a Phoenician and left in Assyria.
This diffusion of Phoenician script
went through the Mediterranean.
This example is an old Phoenician
inscription which attests links
to the homeland with the evocation
of Lebanon [inaudible]
from the 8th century.
And then to the west Mediterranean.
This inscription of [inaudible] in
Sardinia is a strange inscription
and the meaning is still
a matter of debate.
But anyway, it is Phoenician
language
and script from the 8th century.
And to [inaudible] all the way
in the 8th century before Christ,
in Sardinia it's important.
It was probably not to be read,
because who would read that?
I mean there were very few people
who could read Phoenician
in Sardinia at the time.
It would more be to affirm
Phoenician presence through it.
It was a question of
a Phoenician presence.
And once more, a question
of identity.
Then the Phoenician
culture was inserted
in west Mediterranean
especially in [inaudible]
and the culture and
script became Punic.
This is a scale of [inaudible]
and on the right an official
inscription of the city of Katago.
This pretty variant of
Phoenician can be compared
to have a comparison more speaking
to what [inaudible] French
is to French from France.
In this case, a link is preserved
between language and script.
So there was an evolution, but early
within the Phoenician ambience.
After the fall and destruction
of Katago, Punic language
and scripts were preserved
for several centuries
in the Numidian regions
of Tunisia and Algeria,
in Sardinia and in Libya.
It was also there and an admission
of local identity within
the Roman Empire.
But I will illustrate it
with something less known.
An inscription on an [inaudible]
found near a shipwreck near St.
Tropez in France.
With a name probably of the
owner of the ship still inscribed
in Punic in the first century BC.
What you have at the
bottom is a copy
of inscriptions of some sailors.
And all these words were inscribed
in different languages in script.
Notably, these in Punic.
Which shows that crews were as
cosmopolitan as they are now.
So that was the diffusion
of Phoenician scripts.
Then I come to my second point,
bilingualism and bigraphism.
That means inscriptions
in two different languages
and two different scripts.
Here we have another phenomenon.
The meeting between cultures and
affirmation of a double identity.
This inscription I go back in
time and go back to [inaudible].
Very near one we saw before.
A confrontation between
Phoenician and Luwian inscriptions
in a strictly Luwian context.
So we have very big inscription.
As for the moment this particular
inscription is the longest
Phoenician inscription ever found.
But it was bilingual and at the
bottom you have the Phoenician
inscription and at the top
part the Luwian inscription.
And it was this inscription that
led to the decipherment of Luwian.
So here we have someone in the
strictly Luwian environment
who wrote the longest Phoenician
inscription every known.
Why? That's a good question.
Another inscription well known,
whose context is better understood.
The Persian inscription, which
three tablets, gold tablets.
Two in Etruscan and one in Punic.
It was in the context
of a political alliance
between the king of
Chiri and Katago.
So the king of Chiri made
an inscription and also said
that he was a devotee of Eshdat.
And then Greece was also a place
where there were meeting
of two cultures.
Here is a [inaudible]
epitaph of a private person.
A Phoenician died in
Greece in Athens.
The inscription is in Athens.
So that is a double inscription
in Greek to be led by locals.
And in Phoenician to be
read by his own community.
But what you see is Phoenician
is first at the top and is longer
than the Greek counterpart.
And then in Malta a dedication
for two different cultures.
[ Inaudible ]
Here also Phoenician
comes first and is longer.
It was dedicated by
Phoenician's brothers
who wrote everything in
Phoenician and Greek.
The third part, the birth
of new alphabets stemming
from the Phoenician Alphabet.
Either through systematic and
[inaudible] process of adaptation
and innovation or through a
progressive and natural evolution.
I will only concentrate on two main
branches which were very productive
and gave all the main
modern alphabets.
On the first part, the
creation of the Greek alphabet,
symbolized by the history of Cadmous
bringing the Phoenician letters,
Phoenician gramata, to the Greeks.
A Greek tradition which
Phoenician adopted on their coins.
And I think we will see them later.
What we can see now
is the possibility
of a fusion intermediate
is now a subject
of this fusion among specialists.
So it goes to the oldest Greek
and we only show this oldest Greek
inscription from the 8th century.
What we see is that the form
of the letters is very close
to the letters of Phoenician
alphabet.
It didn't have any evolution at the
time for those Phoenician letters.
But the system is already
a new one with vowels.
That was the main invention
of the Greeks.
And for example, from right to left
you can see [inaudible] with an O
and this aleph already as an R.
And this alphabet was the origin
of the Etruscan alphabet, ancestor
of our modern Latin alphabet.
So that is well known.
I will go quickly to the other
branch because I don't need
to explain the Latin alphabet here.
The second branch which is also very
interesting, perhaps less known,
is the evolution to
the Aramaic alphabet.
Here we don't have an
innovation, a fundamental change,
as there was in the Greek alphabet.
It's a progressive evolution
from the Phoenician alphabet
without any revolutionary change.
Here are inscriptions
of the 9th century.
So about the same time as
the inscriptions of Byblos
of which I showed one
at the beginning.
An inscription of Hazal
and the second one
of Zaku mentioned in Baghdad.
Hazal and Baghdad are
well known from the Bible.
So this way we can give
dates to these inscriptions.
9th century.
The alphabet is exactly the same
as in Phoenician inscription.
I mean, we can distinguish
the language,
but not the script of that time.
Then the alphabet was
used by Assyrians
within the Assyrian empire.
It was diffused in the near east
through the deportation
of Aramaic population.
And this fresco from [inaudible]
is very symbolic of the fact
that the Assyrian empire
used both a system --
cuneiform on clay tablets on
the right and Aramaic alphabet
on raw material on the left.
And then what was the Phoenician
alphabet was even written on tablets
within the Assyrian civilization.
This from the Louvre.
Yes, I am going quickly.
So it diffused all around Asia.
And I will just give you
examples with these inscriptions
which were found quite recently
on the antiquity market.
And it's Aramaic inscription from
[inaudible] region corresponding
with north Afghanistan
and Uzbekistan.
And it's an illustration
of the [inaudible] empire.
So four centuries before Christ.
And around 300 BC Aramaic
was used by Ashakur,
founder of the first Indian Empire,
the Maurya Empire that he converted
to Buddhism and it's
written in Aramaic.
A later variant of Aramaic,
this script from Odessa
diffused to central Asia.
You have the [inaudible].
And up to China.
The very famous [inaudible] from
the 8th century written in Chinese
and Syriac, so Aramaic with
what was the original for that.
At the end of antiquity,
the alphabetical system
of script was used from the Atlantic
coast of Europe and North Africa
to central Asia and
then China and India.
And at the end I want you to
see also this alphabet coming
to other languages and scripts.
Alphabetic Aramaic used
in the Iranian context
in the 1st century
AD in central Asia.
And so that is the Aramaic
alphabet writing Iranian.
Then transferred to
write an Indian language
and becoming an Indian [inaudible].
And it's normal in
alphabets, but it's stemming
from Phoenician alphabet
through Aramaic.
And last but not least, the
birth of the Arab script.
With this inscription which
is also this picture tribute
to a friend Eric Gubal,
because this monument is
in [Foreign name] in Brussels.
This is an inscription 512
AD on the lintel of a church.
And it was first dated
Arabic inscription.
So you just see on the
top a Syriac inscription
but just on the lower part.
That is the oldest dated
Arabic inscription every known.
Dated I mean.
A trilingual inscription
[inaudible] Greek.
So with this diffusion from
Phoenician to Arabic we come
to the fact that Phoenician
was really the origin
of what is very important
in our civilization.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: So
now Dr. Elizabeth Fontan,
the honorary chief
curator of Heritage
in France, will be speaking.
After a stint at the National
Ceramic Museum of Sevres
and the generally respected museums,
the bulk of her career has been
in the department of eastern
antiquities of the Louvre Museum.
Where she was responsible
for collections on Assyria,
Phoenicia, Palestine -- thank you.
Jordan, as well as those on Syria
and Cyprus in the 1st millennium BC.
She was a scientific exhibition
curator from Khorsabad to Paris.
And the discovery of Assyria
at Louvre Museum in 1993.
And from here to Carthage, the
Mediterranean of the Phoenicians
and the Arab World
Institute in Paris in 2007.
She is one of the editors
of the catalog traditional
Phoenician sculpture at the Louvre,
and the department of
eastern antiquities.
She has worked in the international
cooperation program of the museum
with Jordan, Syria and Palestine,
with a lecture at the Louvre.
Her publications in preparation
include the Ivories of [inaudible],
Syria and the consuls,
collectors and traders in Sidon.
And we will have a big presentation
after which we will have a break.
Okay. Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Elizabeth Fontan: Ladies
and gentlemen, it is a great honor
for me to speak in this place.
The first pieces from
Phoenicia entered the Louvre
in the middle of the 19th century.
They came from Amrit,
Byblos and Sidon.
The sarcophagus of
Eshmunazar was presented
to the Louvre by [inaudible]
in 1855.
The collection from Tyre was
assembled a few years later
into three different ways.
Scientific missions,
acquisition from local dealers
and antiquaries and
official excavation.
The most important of the scientific
missions and the most famous is
of course the one led me
Earnest Renan [French word].
Renan was given by Emperor
Napoleon III a scientific mission
for the purpose of
conducting epigraphic
and archaeological research
in Palestine and in Syria.
This mission happened to take
place right at the same time
as the French military expedition
sent to protect the Christians.
Renan sailed on October 21st,
1860 and left Beirut the
following year on October 10th.
He decided to split his research
into four campaigns from north
to south, Rad and Amrit,
Byblos, Sidon and Tyre.
He wishes to include in each
campaign the most important places
and to survey as completely
as possible the surroundings.
With the help of the French
army, especially the marine,
this program was achieved
within six months.
Renan started the exploration
of Tyre on March 4th 1861.
He knew it would be difficult
to reach the deepest levels.
The ancient city was
covered by the modern town.
And he was afraid having no
reward in this prestigious site.
The oldest item found in
Tyre is this [inaudible] head
of a [inaudible] discovered
in an eight-meter deep trench
on the location of the old Tyre.
This head was inserted in the
body made on the [inaudible].
See for comparison
figurine now in the Louvre,
dating from the iron age too.
That is 8-7th century BC.
Renan wished to explore
continental town
on the mainland called [inaudible].
But he was not successful
in the surrounding area.
At Naphid he discovered a
fragmentary marble sarcophagus
decorated with figures in
the Phoenician tradition.
Caesar on the lid,
mixed with Roman motifs.
[ Inaudible ]
In April, Renan started excavating
Umel-Ahmed, or as they said,
Umel-Ahamed, ancient
[inaudible] situated
at 19 kilometers south of Tyre.
He found there a lot of
fragments of sculptures.
Human heads, lower part
of a standing man wearing a
shunted skirt, bodies of sphinxes.
A throne, status throne.
And some pieces of architecture,
a [inaudible] and fragments
of [inaudible] as well
as winged [inaudible].
Among the finds were three pieces.
Dedication to the god Baalshamin,
a fragment of a [inaudible]
dedicated to the god [inaudible].
And there is her statue
also dedicated
to [inaudible] god of [inaudible].
One of the master pieces of the
[inaudible] is the floor mosaic
from St. Christopher
church dated 575 AD.
It was recovered in very
good state of conservation.
And it was retrieved from its
original location by a specialist
from [inaudible] to
be sent to Paris.
Since 2012 it is on display in
the new late antiquity galleries
for the first time in
its complete composition.
Another scientific mission provides
the Louvre with a piece from Tyre.
Albert Immanuel Gilbreth called
[inaudible] realized three missions.
During the third one in 1864-1865
he brought a stain showing a
veiled woman.
It was supposed to come from
Tyre, but from the stylistic point
of view it was [inaudible].
Two families from Southern
Lebanon played a significant role
in the constitution of the
Phoenician collection of the Louvre
in the second half
of the 19th century
and at the beginning of the 20th.
[ Inaudible ]
At the end of the 18th century
when he was a consul
for several countries.
France, Spain but also
the United States.
His son moved to Sidon in 1853.
Vice consul of Franc, he was very
active in the search of antiquities.
And he discovered the
sarcophagus of Eshmunanzar.
Later, he went to work
for the [French name]
and gave this marble relic
from [inaudible] depicting
a Phoenician theme.
[Inaudible] in front of one
incense burner with [inaudible].
His youngest son [inaudible]
was a [inaudible]
in Sidon and later in Paris.
In 1882 his own marble
[inaudible] got to be reused
in the wall of the house in Sour.
Five members of the family, two
brothers [inaudible] and three
of the sons, Michel,
Sigmund and Ferdinand,
were involved in the antiquity
market, mostly in their hometown.
They didn't claim to be scholars.
Their trade was a way
of earning their living.
They provided [inaudible]
with small artifacts.
Glass flasks, [inaudible] a fragment
of a stone basin which is said
to have been collected
on the seashore
in the vicinity of
the Egyptian harbor.
It is inscribed with
a Phoenician name.
They also saw [inaudible]
characteristic of the Tyre
with the twisted columns.
[Inaudible] was led
to work at [inaudible]
by the French scholar [French name]
to continue the site exploration.
They found a series of male statues
in Egyptian style presumably
[inaudible].
Unfortunately, all headless.
These figures are set against
[inaudible] except for one.
The bottom left.
Two of them are dedicated on the
back of the pillar to Baalshamin.
One to the got El,
the other to Ozaris.
They also sent to the Louvre several
limestone [inaudible] depicting
priests wearing Persian cloth.
Veiled woman and a
couple facing each other.
This type of structure
was unknown to Renan.
And we still do not know the
precise location they were found
in the site.
[ Inaudible ]
And assembled a fine collection.
He bought in the village of
Mashuk an inscription dated
to the 53rd year of Tyre and he
sold it to the Louvre in 1885.
In Sour they discovered pieces
of an inscribed monument looking
like a [inaudible] which was sent
to the museum by [inaudible].
At the beginning of
the last century,
the Jesuit father Sebastian [French
name] was able to buy some pieces
with fund supplied by [French name],
pieces which were transferred
to the Louvre later.
An inscribed [inaudible] on
the right from [inaudible].
And two [inaudible]
showing [inaudible].
[ Inaudible ]
And also lead weight showing
on one side and the sign
of [inaudible] on the other.
After the first World War,
official excavations were organized
in Lebanon by [French name]
during the French mandate.
[French name] was in
charge of excavating Tyre
and its surrounding
in 1921 and 1922.
[French name] conducted a
[inaudible] at [inaudible] in 1921.
In the 1930's the Jesuit father
[French name] realized a survey
and submarine excavation
in the Tyre harbor.
Later [French name]
resumed excavation
in [inaudible] in 1943-45.
But at the time there
was no longer any sharing
of the records of the excavation.
And the pieces discovered are now
in the National Museum in Beirut.
Since the end of the French
mandate, the collection
in the Louvre was completed
by a few purchases.
[ Inaudible ]
Which is said to have been
found on the seashore at Sour,
and is inscribed with
dedication to [inaudible] in Tyre.
A marbles stone with a full line
dedication to [inaudible] also.
And [inaudible] statuettes from a
deposit at the bottom of the sea.
To conclude this brief
overview we can see
that in the Phoenician collection
of the Louvre very few pieces were
found on the island of Tyre itself.
Many more come from
its surroundings,
notably from [inaudible].
Thank you for your attention.
[ Applause ]
>> Okay, good morning
ladies and gentlemen.
And welcome to our second panel.
Phoenician commerce and exchange.
Our first speaker, Dr.
Frederique Duyrat is the director
of the department of
coins, metals and antiques
of the Bibliotheque
Natiaonle du France.
From 2001-2009 she was assistant
professor in Greek history
at the University of
Elyon from France.
And a member of the
Institute University de France
between 2006 and 2009.
From 2010-2013 she was curator
of Greek coins in the department
of coins, metals and antiques at the
Bibliotheque Nationale du France.
Until she was offered
the position of director
of this department
in September 2013.
She has been an associate
researcher at the [French name],
a physics laboratory specializing
in the elemental analyses
of the metal of coins
from 2002-2013.
And is now associated through the
research team of [French name]
at the University of Paris Sorbonne.
And the [French word] of
the University of Paris.
She presented in [French name] at
the Sorbonne in 2010 to be published
by the American Numismatic Society.
Lost and Found: Monetary Behavior
in Acaminit and Hellenistic Syria.
She is the editor of the
[French name] published
by the Bibliotheque
Nationale du France.
And is one of the directors
of the Review Numismatique.
And a member of the board of the
Societe Francaise du Numismatique.
She has published a
book and 28 articles
and edited four conferences related
to numismatics or economic history.
Please welcome Dr.
Frederique Duyrat.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Frederique Duyrat:
Well, first of all,
I wanted to thank the association
for the invitation of speaking
at the Library of Congress.
Being myself a member of
staff of a national library,
it's a great honor to be here.
But I'm here to speak about the
coinage or Tyre in antiquity.
Tyre was one of the most
prominent cities during antiquity.
Its coinage reflects its power.
One of the first names active
in its coinage is an important
tool to write the history.
Beginning a little before the
middle of the 5th century BC,
it did appear during
the 3rd century AD.
Before using coinage,
Tyre like other cities
in the east used commodity money
or what we call hack silver.
That means fragments of silver.
Either pieces of jewelry
or any silver.
Weight to now the values.
On this you can see that even coins,
Greek coins, were used like that.
Cut as if it were just
silver [inaudible].
From the latter half of the 6th
century BC silver coins started
circulating in the east.
The oldest coin known was found in
the [inaudible] north of the mouth
of the [inaudible] river and
was buried around 525-520 BC.
It only contained foreign
coinage struck
in Macedonia, Thrace and Cyprus.
So foreign coins.
By the end of the 5th century,
[inaudible] bear witness
to the first strikes of finished
coins from Sidon and Tyre.
Tyre built a complete monetary
system from the beginning.
The major denomination was the
shekel, weighing around 13.5 grams.
And it has a complete succession of
diffusion from the quarter shekel,
the thirty-second of
shekel and even tiny coins
that weighted only 0.06 grams, so
really tiny, tiny silver coins.
During the 4th century
there were even brown coins.
Compared to the variety
of the Phoenician city
coinage during the same period,
Tyre's typology is
limited to two main groups.
The [inaudible] shows a dolphin
jumping above a wave with a shell
in the [inaudible] on the rivers.
[ Inaudible ]
This first group was spread
during the 5th century.
On the second group,
the largest by far,
struck during the 4th century BC.
A bearded god rides a
winged seahorse to ride
above waves and on a dolphin.
The rivers is represented the same
way as in the 5th century group.
This 4th century group has totally
different profile from the 5th one.
The Phoenician coins
gain an increasing place
in circulation during that period.
They even constituted [inaudible].
Sidon vastly dominates with nearly
half of [inaudible] and the area
of circulation that
goes beyond the limits
of its home regional
zone of influence.
But Tyre has produced nearly
of 10% of whole specimens
and its coins circulate
rather widely.
The image chosen by the Tyrians
too strike their coins provides
indication of what the city wanted
to be considered as
its official banner.
The [inaudible] during the
whole Persian period is a hawk
with a hawk body wearing
the Egyptian insignia
of power, a scepter and a flame.
The Egyptian influence reminds
us of the long-lasting commercial
and political relationship of
the Phoenician cities with Egypt.
Which is peculiar to Tyre, but
also sometimes from [inaudible]
and Sidon is the importance
given to the sea.
A dolphin jumping above
a wave, the shell,
the bearded god riding a
seahorse are all related
to the sea power of Tyre.
The interesting thing is
that the seahorse is winged.
It is at the same time
a sea and sky animal.
Such an [inaudible] which
is completely abnormal
in the Greek context is not puzzling
since the Phoenicians gods can have
at the same time power
of earth and sky.
Therefore such an animal
is a convenient mount.
At the end of 333 BC, Alexander
the great won the battle of Issus
and entered Phoenicia to consolidate
his victory by the diminishing
of the Mediterranean coast.
The control of the coastal cities
of Cyprus would guarantee him
that the Persian fleets
would be kept away
when it could have [inaudible].
Raddus, Byblos and Sidon
almost immediately submitted
to the Macedonian king.
[ Inaudible ]
To the considerable
benefit of Alexander.
He acted quickly, prompting
the [inaudible]
of the city and their fleets.
Rapidly thereafter,
fleets of [inaudible]
and Cyrus joined his camp.
But Tauria and Giza remained
the only cities to resist.
The siege of Tyre lasted
from January to July 332 BC.
However, after he had
conquered the city,
it seemed that Alexander
didn't change the regime,
the political regime.
At this part of the resistance,
Tyre kept a king designated by order
of Alexander from among the
members of the former royal family.
All the formerly Phoenician cities,
Raddus, Byblos, Sidon and Tyre,
already issued coins in 333.
They quickly started to
strike with Alexander's type.
The head of Heracles.
Alexander sitting on the throne,
an eagle in his right
hand on the reverse.
You can see on that coin, few
Phoenician coins on the reverse
of the coin, just in front of those.
It is the name of the
reigning Tyrian king.
It's the first and the last letter
in Phoenician in the
name of the king.
Phoenicia was the theater
of an essential [inaudible],
the monetary history of Alexander.
The creation of a gold
coinage after July 332.
And the surrounding of Tyre.
This will explain the novel
reverse type he chose.
A [inaudible] holding
what we call a stylus,
a long tool she's got
on her left shoulder.
The stylus was the
banner for [inaudible],
usually taken as a
trophy by the winner.
And it is here a keen reminder of
his victory on the city of Tyre.
After Alexander's day in 323 BC,
the [inaudible] was at war due
to the competition between
Alexander's companion.
[Inaudible] silver and gold
coins with Alexander's types
and his name in very large amounts.
And Tyre was one of the main mints.
The circulation of these
coins was very wide,
as far as Alexander's
treks in the east.
After 301 Phoenicia was part
of a wider region called Syria
and Phoenicia in the hands of
Ptolemy I, new king of Egypt,
and former companion
of Alexander the Great.
He and his son, Ptolemy II,
completely transformed the
monetary system of the kingdom
and its dependencies by
introducing a standard [inaudible]
and the [inaudible] standard
with have been widely used
as Alexander chose
it for its coinage.
Ptolemy I created a closed monetary
system with mandatory exchange
at borders, excluding
all foreign coins.
In Egypt, the sole mint was
Alexandria, but in Syria
and Phoenician several mints
were opened, one of them Tyre.
From 260 the local mints
seem to have supplied most
of the needs of the area.
Tyre signed its prediction with a
monogram written with Greek letters.
But you can see the front
of the eagle on the rivers.
And the club.
Distinctive attributes of the god
protector of the city, Melqart.
At the beginning of the second
century, [inaudible] king
of Syria grabbed Syria
and Phoenicia.
However, he didn't change
the monetary system.
It is only at the end
of the second century BC
when the [inaudible] dynasty weakens
that Tyre started its
own autonomous coinage.
From 126 BC Tyre issued
this autonomous coinage.
That means coin with its own type
and the name and titles of the city.
From the iconographic point of view,
the coinage of Tyre
was relatively poor.
These symbols were most common
during the Persian period.
[Inaudible] and shells
are secondary symbols.
A palm tree and Melqart
were all common.
This god patron of the
city was represented young,
wearing a laurel reef.
His identities of use thanks
to the associated club
that you can see here
on the reverse of the.
And the appearance of the god
himself with a stout neck,
strong chin, his head occupying
all the available surface
of the [inaudible].
It is a mighty god whose power
comes from its physical strength.
[ Inaudible ]
And then a symbol of an
economically reliable coinage.
A monogram of the city and its name
in full letters appear
on the reverse.
Sometimes on other
coins a Atike goddess
of the city fortune is
represented on autonomous bronze
with a palm tree on the reverse.
She's probably the Greek
representation of Serte,
protective goddess of the city.
All other deities of city,
skills and politics are
absent from the coinage.
A political object, coins bear
the image of gods in charge
of the political activity
of the community.
Syria would transfer into
a Roman province in 64 BC.
Syria brought change to the coinage.
Tyre kept its autonomous
types and its issues
of autonomous silver coins continued
during the first century AD.
So real change occurred
during the 2nd century AD
with in particular the
development of references
to founding myths and local cults.
The latter were evoked through
a picture [inaudible] positional
[inaudible] objects related to
religious festivals and comparisons.
Agonistic palms of
victory and so on.
[ Inaudible ]
During the Hellenistic
period detailed depictions
of founding myth.
So you have here one example
of the coin in the 1st century.
Here you can see the change
because the reverse --
on the obverse you have the emperor.
On the reverse you have a very
detailed scene depicting what we
call the Ambrosian works.
They were erected in the shrine
of Heracles Melqart
under an olive tree.
They were associated
with the foundation
of the city though the particulars
of the foundation remain unknown.
They are presented as Talas
on bronze coins spread
during the 3rd century AD.
So identification is clear
since the name is written
on them, Ambrosia Petra.
Under the exit line, a dog
and a [inaudible] remind us
of the myth explaining how the
[inaudible] were discovered.
The famous Tyrian purple was
extracted from this shell.
Another coin struck between
244 and 249 AD shows Cadmous.
I'm sorry for the quality, but
this is a very, very rare coin
and this is the one we've
got in the library in Paris.
So you can hardly see it
here, but it's very clear
when you read it directly.
So it shows Cadmous, king of Tyre
on the right, giving a [inaudible]
to three men on the left.
If it's not just with emirs.
You've got a legion and
there's the exit line.
Because you have the first
letter of the work Elanos
at the feet of the three men.
And there's a man on the right.
You have cad for Cadmous.
The scene represents Cadmous
giving the alphabet to the Greeks.
An eastern heritage for
the Greek civilization.
Then the 2nd and 3rd
century AD coin designs
of Tyre are multiple
educational and political.
They contrast strongly with the more
enigmatic sobriety of the issues
of the Persian and
Hellenistic periods.
They bear witness to changes
in the religious practice
from the 2nd century AD in contrast
to the preceding long-lasting
religious rights.
They are also a political program
enhancing the central relationships
and heritage between Phoenicia
and the Greek world at a time
when Phoenicia was deeply
influenced by Greek culture.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Dr. Duyrat, for
a very intriguing presentation.
Our next presenter is
Dr. Patrick McGovern,
who direct the biomolecular
archaeology project
at the University of Pennsylvania
museum in Philadelphia.
Where he's also an adjunct
professor of anthropology
and consulting scholar
in the near east section.
Over the past two years he
has pioneered the exciting
interdisciplinary field of
biomolecular archaeology
which is yielding whole new
chapters concerning human ancestry,
medical practice and ancient
cuisines and beverages.
He has excavated extensively in
the Middle East, including Lebanon,
Canaanite and Phoenician Sarafond.
He is the author of Ancient
Wine: The Search for the Origins
of Viniculture, published
in 2003-04.
And most recently Uncorking
the Past: The Quest for Wine,
Beer and other Alcoholic Beverages.
Without further ado,
Dr. Patrick McGovern.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Patrick McGovern: Thank you.
I'm very happy to be here.
And I'm thankful to the Tyre
committee for inviting me to talk
about two of the technological
and artistic creations
of the Phoenicians.
I mean, the Phoenicians are
responsible for a great deal.
We've heard about the alphabet,
we've heard about some
coinage, ship building.
There's metalworking, glass making.
And I'm going to talk about
royal purple and wine.
My first experience in
archaeology was actually in Lebanon
at a site not too far
from Tyre called Surepta,
or Sarafond which is
only about 11 kilometers
as the crow flies north of Tyre.
So I have a great affinity
for Lebanon
and what it really represents.
Because I think it took technology
and art and transferred them
across the Mediterranean and
eventually to the whole world.
So it's a very special country
and I think we need to find
out a great deal more about it.
I mean, I'm really saddened by
the events since the civil war
and so forth, and how difficult
it is to excavate in that country.
But I think it holds secrets
that we really can't imagine.
I think architecture too.
We've heard about the Tyre temple
and we're going to hear more
about that this afternoon.
So I think architecture and temple
worship, religion, theater, music.
There's a whole series of
contributions that the Phoenicians
and the Canaanites, the predecessors
of Phoenicians, contributed.
So I'm going to talk about
royal purple as a good example,
or Tyrian purple we can call it.
Because there's a Greek
myth you could say
that the Phoenicians are the ones
who developed purple initially
or even back to the Canaanites.
And that the words for
Phoenicia and Canaan do derive
from ancient words for purple.
So this is very integral to the
Canaanites and the Phoenicians.
Now here we see this myth
of Heracles walking along the
shore of Tyre with his dog.
And the dog is biting
into different shells.
And this is the Greek idea of how
maybe it could have been discovered.
The dog bites into a murex shell
which has the purple dye gland.
And I'll show that to
you a little bit later.
And that inspires Heracles
then to take the dye and make
up textiles for his consort goddess.
And so begins the royal
purple dye making.
But we have more definitive
archaeological evidence.
And it comes from the site of
Surepta where I worked in 1974
as Israeli jets pounded
the local Palestinian camp.
You had to be very intrepid to
work at Surepta in those days.
And Leila Badre can attest to that
because she was there
at the same time.
And it is a site that's
located between Tyre and Sidon,
about halfway in between.
And when they started getting
down into the late bronze,
early iron age levels, this is
from about 1300 BC to 1100 BC.
This is one of the few homeland
Canaanite/Phoenician sites
that has been excavated.
Now Sidon is getting
a lot more information
and we hope that Tyre will as well.
We came down onto an
industrial area.
This is done by the University
of Pennsylvania Museum
under James Pritchard who some
of you may know or have heard of.
We started finding Canaanite jars.
I was a graduate student at
this time, so I was working
on the pottery and going
through it very carefully.
And you'll see here that this
industrial area had kilns
for making the pottery.
But in addition it also had purple
colored shards on the inside
of amphoras or Canaanite jars.
And also processing
vats for making the dye.
And when we saw these purple colored
shards, our immediate instincts was
that these were possibly
real Tyrian purple.
Now they could be from an inorganic
coloring like manganese or iron.
But if they were the
real Tyrian royal purple,
they would be an organic compound.
And we had just started in
on doing organic analyses
at the University of
Pennsylvania museum.
First I'd work on pottery
and glass and so forth.
And then I was always very
interested in organic chemistry.
And we were just developing the
techniques 20 years ago to be able
to analyze organic compounds and
see what the ancient dye might be
or ancient food or whatever.
And so this is a very small shard
that we worked with from Surepta
that had the purple
color on the inside.
It was from an amphora.
And for those who are
chemically challenged among you,
I'm not going to give
you all the details.
We've published extensively
on the chemical results.
And we have used spectroscopic
techniques.
Mass spectrometry works very well.
And there's a particular
vat dye test that you can do
that almost certainly
shows that we're dealing
with what's called
6-6-prime dibromoindigotin.
It's an indigo compound
that has two bromines,
one on each side of the molecule.
And the indigo of course gives blue.
But if you put the bromines on, it
switches the color over to purple.
And there's a lot of
fascinating details about this dye
and I'll refer you again to some
of the articles I've written about.
It comes from a gland,
as I mentioned,
in the murex mollusk that's
found in the Mediterranean.
There's three different species.
And this is an example where you
can see it's a yellowish fluid
that comes out of this gland,
called the hypobranchial gland.
And when it's exposed to light
and air, it changes to purple.
So it's something that people
could have discovered quite easily.
And there's related species of
mollusks all over the world.
So the ancient Mayans, Chinese,
Incans and so forth
discovered related species.
And if you're using it as
a food source and you start
to handle the Murex, you're
going to get it on your fingers.
And it is a very fast dye.
It's very hard to remove.
So people would have realized
it was a good textile dye
and started using it
for that purpose.
Okay, so that is a little
glimpse of the royal purple.
You know, there's lots
more I could say about it.
But now I want to move
on to another luxury good
which also has technological
and artistic ramifications,
and that's ancient wine.
Which I've written a book about.
So you're welcome to ask me about.
And I also hope we'll be having --
on that first slide at the beginning
I showed a view of the Baca valley
where winemaking has probably
gone on for thousands of years.
Now this is a map that shows in
purple, appropriately enough,
and I'm glad that some of
you are wearing purple today.
Where the wild grapevine,
the wild Eurasian grapevine,
vitis vinifera, grows today.
And we think that basically
it's the same region.
And you'll notice that the
area -- well before I do that,
you'll notice that Lebanon is
at the most southerly extent
of the wild grape vine.
So when humans came out of
Africa say 100,000 years ago
and they crossed over the Sinai
and up into the near east,
they would see the grape for
the first time in Lebanon.
And I think that they would be
quite interested in this fruit.
[ Laughter ]
And so they would maybe
start experimenting with it.
But now so far we have a
project now up in Georgia
in the Caucuses looking at the
earliest evidence for winemaking
and for the domestication
of the grapevine.
It appears that the
domestication occurs somewhere
in the mountainous
region of the near east.
It could be up in the Caucuses, but
it could also be near eastern Turkey
and the Taurus mountains,
over to the Zagros mountains.
But even down into Lebanon.
And unfortunately we've had no real
gathering of grapes and DNA analyses
in Lebanon to test you know, whether
it could have first merged there.
But we do know that the Canaanites
and then the Phoenicians
are very much involved
in spreading the wine
culture, wherever it emerges.
And by wine culture mean
something like Lebanon today,
where wine can become very much --
of course you have
Ararack and what have you.
Wine can become very
central to the economy,
the social life, the religion.
And sort of embeds itself right into
the culture in a very profound way.
But we do see in later periods
how this wine culture then spread
principally from the
Canaanite Phoenician area.
So around 4000 BC -- we probably had
the emergence of the wine culture
around 6000 BC in the
mountainous areas of the near east.
Then by 4000 BC it had spread
down to the Jordan valley.
And we have grape seeds
of domesticated grape
that have been found
about that time.
And then ultimately
it goes on to Egypt
where you'll notice Egypt did
not have the wild grapevine.
You had to bring in the
domesticated grapevine.
And who did that?
Well it was the Canaanites
and the Phoenicians.
And I'll show you a few more
slides to illustrate that.
But then the Phoenicians also
took the grape and wine culture
across the Mediterranean.
And we've done a lot of analyses
now on vessels from Crete
and other parts of even the
western Mediterranean that show
that at least by 2200 BC
wine was being made on Crete.
So the Greeks are absorbing
the wine culture.
And the earliest shipwreck in
the Mediterranean from Uluburun,
which is just off the
southern coast of Turkey,
dated about 1350 BC,
is a Canaanite ship.
So here the Canaanites were
transporting all sorts of goods
and spreading out into
the Mediterranean,
establishing colonies and so forth.
And you'll see there
are some amphoras.
This is a reconstructed view
of what the Uluburun shipwreck
would have looked like.
Because a lot of the goods were
spread out along a very steep slope.
So they tried to figure out what the
weight, the ballast would have been
on certain parts of the ship and
the different sizes of amphoras.
And we are just publishing
an article that shows
that they had wine
on board this ship.
This has been sometimes
controversial.
[ Laughter ]
I think if you're Canaanites you
have wine on board your ship.
And then we did an analysis of
other amphoras that were found
in shipwrecks from the 8th
century BC off of Ashkelon.
And they were carrying an
enormous number of amphoras.
This is a photograph by
remotely operated submersible.
But it showed hundreds
of amphoras in the ships.
And there were two ships.
And they were given the ships
Tanit, and Elissa or Dido.
And they were carrying,
according to our analysis, wine.
Now the wine in this case
also has a resin in it.
It could be pine resin
or terabinth resin.
And that helps to keep
it from spoiling.
So they then went out across to
Greece and Crete as I mentioned.
And I think ultimately, according
to another article that we've done
in the proceedings from the
National Academy of Sciences --
and these are available on my
website if you're interested.
The French ultimately got winemaking
and the wine culture
through the Etruscans.
This occurs around the
8th, 7th, 6th century BC.
But my belief, and I
think it will be shown
as more shipwrecks are excavated,
is that the Phoenicians
are really the ones
that transferred the wine culture
and the domesticated
grapevine to the Etruscans.
And then ultimately to the French.
So the beginnings of winemaking in
France go back to the Phoenicians,
which is not all that surprising.
I hope I'm not upsetting anybody.
[ Applause ]
And just to give you
some examples from Egypt
of how important the Canaanites were
there, one of the earliest tombs
of a pharaoh is one of Scorpion
I at Abidos around 3150 BC.
And he had 700 jars of
wine, about 4,500 liters
of wine put into his tomb.
So the king was buried on a bed
on the back there with
his mace in hand.
And then there was beer and bread
and so forth in the middle chambers.
And then there were three sort
of wine cellars, you know,
stacked up with these jars.
And we were able show that
this again was a resinated wine
that had figs put into it.
It also had thyme and savory.
You were eating zatar this morning.
We have shown that some
of the earliest wine --
and this was probably, according
to the neutron activation analyses
of the pottery, it comes from
the Jordan valley in this case.
And the surrounding hill country
where the wine was
then exported to Egypt.
And that gave the Egyptians
the impetus to set
up their own wine industry
around 3000 BC.
And we have these beautiful
depictions of course
as probably some of
you have seen in Egypt
of how the winemaking was done.
Well, this is a pretty
sophisticated system that goes back
to the beginning of the old kingdom.
I mean, I'm showing a fresco
here from the new kingdom.
But there's equal examples
from the old kingdom.
It shows how they were able
to have arbors or pergolas
with grapes growing up
high, which blocks the sun.
Because you're in a very hot
climate in the Nile delta.
So it's the Canaanites who are
transplanting the grapevine
to the delta, setting up the
winemaking industry there.
And using very advanced
horticultural methods.
They even had irrigation
of single plants we see
in some of the illustrations.
And of course doing the stomping
operation, putting it into jars,
knowing how to seal it, how to do
the fermentation and how to keep it.
And this influence
ultimately comes from Lebanon.
We know from the textile evidence
of the Greeks and so forth
that Lebanese wine, especially
Bybline or Byblos wine,
was renowned in the ancient world as
being the equal of any Greek wine.
They said it was comparable
to the Lesbos wine.
And it was very much a part
of ceremonies in Lebanon.
We have from the Ras Shamra texts
that they had special worship
and meals and ceremonies
for the ancestors,
which features lots of wine.
Which also the gods Baal and
Hel sometimes overindulged in.
So we've got a culture there that
is definitely a wine-based culture.
And yet we know very little about it
because we have not done
any analyses of vessels
from the homeland of Phoenician
area that we can really rely on.
Or at least there might be some
in progress that suggest Cartamum,
but I kind of wonder about that.
But we've got these spectacular
vases, the mushroom-lipped juglet
and the amphora and so forth
that need to be analyzed.
And on this particular
sarcophagus of Hiram of Byblos,
we see him holding
a cup in his hand.
And what was that cup filled with?
Well, we would think
it would be with wine.
But we still have yet to prove this.
And we really need a lot
more work and protection
of the antiquities in Lebanon.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you very much,
Dr. McGovern.
Our next speaker is
Dr. Peter Von Dommelen.
He's an archaeologist studying
cross cultural interactions
and colonial connections in
the ancient Mediterranean.
Especially in the Phoenician
and Punic worlds.
His research concerns topics like
migration, rule of households,
ancient agriculture and landscapes
in the western Mediterranean
in both ancient and
more recent times.
They also structured long-term
field work and ceramic studies
on the island of Sardinia, Italy.
He's the Dukowski family professor
of archaeology and professor
of anthropology at Brown University
in Providence, Rhode Island.
And has held visiting professorships
at University of Valencia in Spain,
[Spanish name] in Spain
and Cagliari in Italy.
Recent publications have appeared
in the Journal of Roman archaeology,
[foreign name] and the Annual
Review of Anthropology.
They also include rural
landscapes of the Punic world,
and the Cambridge prehistory of the
bronze and iron age Mediterranean.
He also serves as co-editor
of the Journal
of Mediterranean Archaeology
and World Archaeology.
Dr. Dommelen.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Peter Dommelen:
Thank you very much
for your kind introduction.
And of course also, my thanks
to the committee for Tyre.
Because it's an honor to speak
here, but also a great pleasure here
to talk to you about
Phoenician archaeology.
As you heard in the
introduction, I'm an archaeologist
and working particularly
on cultural interaction.
So what happens when people
migrate, go and work somewhere else
and how they learn
things from others,
how they start doing
things in different ways?
And in the process sort of come
up with novel ways of doing that
or consuming things as well.
And most of my research over
the past 25 years has been
involving Phoenicians.
But without going into Lebanon
myself, which is still a place
where I have to go, I must confess.
Because all of my work in
fact has been concentrated
in the west Mediterranean and
that is what I will be speaking
about here.
So it's under the heading
of material connections.
Because the fate of Tyre is, as
we've heard and as we've seen
to some extent or a large
extent, based on the city itself.
But not just and not only that,
but it's also on the
overseas connections,
what Tyrians were doing
overseas and what they were
up to in those faraway places.
And archaeology is actually crucial
for understanding these things.
Archaeology is about stuff,
about things that you find,
and hence they make up
these material connections.
Because this is obviously a huge
and vast topic, I'm only going
to be touching on a
couple of points today
because of the constraints of time.
And what I want to highlight is to
take you on a kind of whirlwind tour
across the Mediterranean and
highlight some of the rapid advances
that the discipline of
archaeology has been making
in this regard as well.
And really in sort of recent years.
And I'm beginning here straight away
with this sort of introductory slide
which I'm not going to say much more
about, other than you're looking
at this wonderful view, which is on
the island or just off the island
of Sardinia where the peninsula in
the background is the colonial site
of Bitia, southeast Sardinia.
And we're looking at
it from the Tophart,
which is one of those weird
sites that were created
in the wester Phoenician
colonial world.
And again, one of the things -- I
don't have time to go into detail,
but we might touch
on it here or there.
Tyre and its overseas connection.
Because it's not just archaeology
that gives us information
about these.
Of course, as we've already seen in
previous talks, there's all sorts
of iconographic sources,
illustrations of various kinds
as we see here in these
reliefs or in this bronze plate.
That was originally fixed on a gate
in Balawat in neo-Syrian period.
And of course there's all
kinds of literary sources.
But even when we look at these
epigraphic and iconographic sources,
we can see very well that
they show us lots of stuff,
lots of things in the archaeology.
We see trees, timber being
transported in forms of tribute
that we just heard a lot about,
these Canaan amphorae
being transported.
And to some extent the amphorae
themselves, the clay vessels.
But of course it wasn't
just about the vessels.
It was clearly, as we heard,
all about the contents of them.
So there's a lot of these.
Even if we look at nonmaterial
sources, it's sort of the material
that sort of makes up those
connections that's paramount there.
But with archaeology we can
actually do something more.
And that's more what
I want to talk about,
sort of these material connections.
They give us insight
in everyday life.
We can talk about what was life in
those colonial oversea settlements?
And what were people up there --
how were they building a
life in faraway places?
So the places I want to
sort of briefly touch
on here is of course Carthage.
How could we not talk about Carthage
when we talk about the west?
But as you can see there the
concentration on the island
of Sardinia, which has all
to do with that as a place
where I conduct my fieldwork.
But very important of course
is the Spanish peninsula,
the Iberian peninsula
where we haven't heard much
about so far today.
But the city Cassis situated
just outside the Mediterranean,
on the Atlantic shores.
That is a key element of this
Phoenician/Tyrian expansion.
So first Carthage.
Carthage, famously founded by Dido
Elissa, and we'll hear much more
about it in a later talk as
I gather from the program.
And we have from our literary
sources, historical sources,
traditional foundation
date of 814 BCE.
And there has been a long discussion
whether that would be reliable.
Because most of the
archaeology was coming
up with somewhat younger dates.
But in fact it is excavations
that have been carried out first
by University of Hamburg and then
more recently by the Universities
of Amsterdam and Ghent in Belgium.
At the site of the
so-called [foreign name]
that have actually come up with
all different kinds of evidence.
Particularly from the
[foreign name] site
that recent radio carbon dates have
actually been pushing back to sort
of the first presence of
settlement at that site
to the end of the 9th century.
So that sort of brings us within
touching distance as it were
of that sort of traditional
foundation date.
So that's sort of one
important achievement
that I would like to highlight.
But what you see in
the larger photo,
which is sort of not
particularly enticing or sort
of attractive you might think.
But in many ways it
is, because in one
of those industrial
or artisanal areas.
And in this case a fairly
early ironworking site
at ancient Carthage.
Another important settlement
site where Phoenicians settled
down very early is on the
southeast, of the southwest,
sorry, of the isle of Sardinia.
In fact on a little island just
off the island of Sardinia itself.
The little Island of Santiago
where the ancient site
of Sulkey was established right
in the middle of the modern town,
as you can see on this aerial.
There you can see most of
the remains are Roman period
or Punic later and so on.
But it's within that
highlighted area there.
That's why there's one area
where much older foundations
of a house were found.
And particularly, zooming much
more in detail at those remains,
we've actually got foundations
of a house probably possibly two
houses here that were established
in the early or mid-8th century.
So that's a little bit later
than the sort of evidence
that we've been getting
from Carthage.
But here what was very
important to establish as well,
these were new foundations.
There was nothing before that.
These were established
on an empty site.
And the life from the
materials as we can find,
that people were living here.
The kind of houses that they were
building there, they seem to be sort
of fully fledged Phoenician houses.
And some of the pottery
sort of illustrated
in that drawing there actually
find some very close matches
to material known from Tyre.
But what also should be noted here,
Sardinia wasn't empty of course.
The island was already
inhabited by local Sardinians,
people of so-called Nuragic culture.
And some of their material culture,
some potsherds have been found
within this early Phoenician
context as well.
Moving further west, really
sort of into the far west
of the Mediterranean,
if not just beyond,
as we're just outside
the Strait of Gibraltar
in Cadis on the modern Lucia.
And here we are overlooking
the area, the salt marshes.
The vast wetlands that sort of
make up that part of the coast.
This has been long an
archaeological problem here.
Because stray finds
we're turning up,
like this little Phoenician
statuette that was actually dragged
up from the sea, so without
any precise foundation.
So if you look it up in
literature of on web sources,
you will find widely varying dates
for this little statuette because by
and large it cannot be
dated with any precision.
Various kinds of Phoenician
amphorae clearly recognizable
as such were turning
up from various places.
But not with any sort
of clear contexts.
But all of this has now sort of
been changed in a very dramatic way
because of what really has
been commercial excavations,
salvage interventions going
on to do with building
within the historical town of Cadis
over the last ten years or so.
And evidence that has sort of
only just been published really.
Now what's been found there at
the site called [foreign name]
because it's actually under
this historical theater
in downtown Cadis, that a whole
Phoenician neighborhood basically
has been brought to light.
There's eight houses contained
in three separate buildings
with a street and a small
side alley connecting to it,
sort of connecting them up.
From the nature of the evidence,
it's actually very clear
that several of the buildings
at least had several stories
as you can see in this
reconstruction here.
And the site has actually
recently been made accessible
to the public under the theater.
So if any of you would
happen to go to St. Lucia,
Cadis should definitely
be a place to go there.
The excellent state of
preservation and excavation
of this evidence has clearly,
very clearly demonstrated the people
here were living Phoenician style.
There's no less than five
or six bread ovens really
to make this flatbread that have
been found in those places there.
Again, all of this dating to
the very end of the 9th century,
sort of early 8th century.
So we're back at the very early
dates, coinciding roughly in time
with the foundation of Carthage.
And what's remarkable therefore,
at that very early date,
people were already going as far as
the very edges of the Mediterranean,
venturing out at least into
the opening up of the Atlantic.
So what we have here clearly
therefore is a Phoenician migrant
community setting themselves up
not just for making a few bucks
on the shoreline or exchanging
something on the beaches or so.
This is something totally different.
This is a very substantial,
well-established trading
and migrant settlement.
What's interesting though, and
that's a little fragment you see
in the very middle
of my slide there,
is it's not just Phoenician material
culture that's being found here.
This pot that you see there is a
vessel from the island of Sardinia
and interestingly not
a Phoenician one.
But this is one, a so-called
Nuragic jug that belongs
within the Nuragic/Sardinia culture.
So the island of Sardinia,
sort of situated centrally
in the west Mediterranean, is
one of those important places.
A very large island, one of the
largest islands of the Mediterranean
that really played a key role
in Phoenician expansion
and its contacts.
The creating of those
contacts across and spanning
over the entire Mediterranean.
And you're looking here at
this wonderful bay which is one
of the best anchorages in this
part of the Mediterranean.
This site and the next one that I'll
be talking about, these two dots
that you see here, the
sites of St. Bernia
and Suraki actually have
come up with evidence.
And again in the last
5-10 years with evidence
of a different mode of being.
A different mode of
migrating and a different mode
of commercial interaction within the
Phoenician world that we have seen.
Because these two sites, St. Bernia
and Suraki are not
Phoenician settlements.
These are indigenous Nuragic
Sardinian settlements.
But we've got clear evidence
here of Phoenician activities
and in fact sort of fairly
permanent presence in those sites.
And in fact, the amphora that you
see here is a local production.
It's not a Canaanite jar.
It's not a Phoenician amphora.
It's locally produced.
The type is sort of
specific to Sardinia.
But it is clearly sort of based
on the Phoenician prototypes.
And this type of jar is called
St. Bernia jar because that's
where it was first recognized,
has actually been found
in Carthage itself as well.
And probably now in Spain too.
And all of this goes together
with all of those other elements
that make up these
material connections.
There's some Greek pottery,
some very early Greek pottery
as you can see as well.
We're talking near the
end of the 9th century.
So again we're back to the very
early horizon Phoenician expansion
in the west.
And of course those sort of
shapeless blocks that are lying
at the foot of the amphora.
These are broken up bronze ingots.
So again, sort of trade in metal
very well demonstrated here.
This slide gives you an indication
of that site of St. Bernia
which you clearly see this
is totally alien in a way
to Phoenician architecture.
Because in fact it isn't.
It is what the site of
St. Bernia looks like.
Typical late bronze age,
iron age architecture
with all the specificities
that I won't be going into.
But what we're looking
at is therefore present
Phoenician context that's
in this case difficult to say within
a well-established local complex.
For better understanding of
how that sort of embedding
of the Phoenician complex could
work in a Nuragic Sardinia context,
we need to look at this other side.
Suraki, sort of lower down
the west coast of Sardinia,
which is in fact the site where I
am directing the excavation project.
At the moment we have got
very extensive evidence
of Phoenician material, like
this mushroom lipped jar
which actually comes from this site.
And some other Greek
and local material.
But it is mostly through --
and again sort of connecting
to the previous paper,
through archaeometric,
technical, scientific investigation
where the pottery was made.
But also through X-ray analysis
understanding how handles are
shaped, how the pot itself was
shaped, how rims were connected.
That gives us an insight into the
very small details of the skills
of artisans, of the
ceramic artisans.
This shows us actually that even if
pots look they are Sardinian style
or they are Phoenician style, we can
see that we must have had masters
and trainees of different
cultural backgrounds.
Because we can see a mixing up,
the body of the pot made
in a Phoenician style.
The pot made to look like a
Phoenician cooking pot for instance.
But the handle or the rim made
with Nuragic indigenous techniques.
So it's really the kind of
interactions that you can only get
when people are sort of
living and working together
on the same place for quite a while.
And it would land here,
this brief survey,
with another material dimension
of what those connections are.
It's actually the ships themselves.
We've heard about the
Uluburun wreck.
We've heard a reference to
the [inaudible] wreck earlier.
This is another sort of
one that's just beginning
to make the literature
because it's so recent.
This is one of two ships that
were found just off the beach
of [inaudible] south of
[inaudible] in [Spanish name]
on the Spanish Mediterranean coast.
This has been excavated and that
actually dates to the 7th century
and it gives us some
material evidence as well.
And it's associated with the sort
of pottery that you see there.
But the other object that you
see on this slide is actually --
it's a model as you
can see on this slide.
It's a bronze model.
That is typically Sardinian
Nuragic model.
And I want to use this
to connect back
to what I've been reminding
you of, is all this interaction
that I've been talking about.
Yes, the Phoenicians clearly
were sailing the whole
of the Mediterranean.
They were setting up shop,
literally in many cases
on the other side of
the Mediterranean.
But they were not the
only ones doing that.
They didn't venture
into a Mediterranean
where they were the first ones.
And you can just remind
yourself when you're going
into those sometimes dangerous
seas, particularly the Strait
of Gibraltar, some of those
places, the Straits of Sicily,
these are not easy seas to navigate.
Local knowledge, local pilots,
local advisors must have
been very important.
And although we don't have any
concrete evidence of Nuragic
or Iberian shipwrecks yet, I
should add, I would hope to add,
it is bronze models like this
one that give us a little glimpse
of those other indigenous
native seagoing skills
that must have existed.
And with whom Phoenicians
must have worked as well.
And it's easily imaginable that
just as has been demonstrated
for the Uluburun wreck in an earlier
period, the crew was very much sort
of culturally mixed
and international.
The same must have been true
in these later periods as well.
So what I want to conclude
therefore on two points is
that this brief survey of
archaeological finds sort
of with the shipwrecks --
again underscores this conventional
representation of the definitions
of skilled sailors and navigators.
And particularly the evidence
of the [inaudible] spells
it out in great detail.
But at the same time, the Sardinian
evidence of the local embedding
of those Phoenician traders,
travelers and sailors as well
as recognizing those Phoenicians
within Carthage and Spain shows
that it is highly unlikely
that these Phoenicians were
the only ones plying the seas
of the Mediterranean in the
early 1st millennium BC.
As we take all this
together therefore,
the new evidence has just been
coming up in these last decades
and richly established accounts
considerably by both detailing
and by complicating
our understanding
of Phoenician overseas
connections and interactions
with west Mediterranean communities.
Thank you for your attention.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you Dr. Van Dommelen.
Our next speaker, Mr. James
Fitzpatrick is a senior partner
at the Washington Law
Firm of Arnold and Porter.
For many years he was
the responsible partner
for the legislative public
policy group in the firm.
He was involved in major
legislative proceedings dealing
with the auto safety issues,
revision of national standards
for copyright protection,
for the recording industry
and professional sports.
As well as the congressional
hearings defending officials
of the Clinton administration.
Senior officials of major
universities and corporate leaders
under fire from Congress.
For 25 years Mr. Fitzpatrick
represented art dealers, museums
and collectors in legislative
and judicial proceedings
establishing fundamental rules
of law at federal and
international level.
Relating to the movement
of antiquities
and cultural properties
around the world.
For 10 years he has taught a course
at Georgetown Law School entitled
Indiana Jones and the Elgin Marbles:
Dealing with the Legal System
relating to Cultural Properties.
Mr. Fitzpatrick received
his law degree
from Indiana University Law School.
He read economics at Corpus
Christie College, Cambridge.
And taught at the London
School of Economics
and Trinity College Dublin.
He has been a central player
in the 1990's culture wars,
in which critics attempted
to shut down federal support
for the National Endowment
of the Arts.
Those battles were fought in the
congress, the courts and the press.
Mr. Fitzpatrick has led a number
of civil rights, civil liberties
and human rights organizations
pressing
for essential liberties
under the law.
Mr. James Fitzpatrick.
[ Applause ]
>> James Fitzpatrick:
Thank you so much.
This has really been an
intellectually engaging morning.
We've had wine.
All of us can go home now and have
that third glass of wine feeling
that you had history on your side.
We've had the Bible,
we've had archaeology,
we're going to have numismatics.
This has been really a quite
strikingly engaging set of lectures.
I must say that this presentation
-- the movies are over, folks.
This is not going to be
a slide presentation.
We're going to go back
to the 19th century
where we converse verbally
rather than visually.
Now one of the basic
laws of lawyering
and advocacy is particularly
when you're last on the program,
you never want to talk
too long to a group
of hungry judges and a hungry jury.
And I'm sure that, Mary Jane,
that's the same thing here.
I'll try to be quick.
My assignment is not, in contrast
to everyone else, Tyre-specific.
What I have been asked
to talk about is
in a broader vector
law and antiquities.
And this is a sprawling subject
involving international law,
national law, US law.
Patrimonial laws around the world.
Criminal and civil law and
the standards that are created
by museum associations and
architectural associations.
To get the full play of all this,
you're going to need to have to come
to Georgetown University
and take my class.
And I welcome you all there.
I'm going to talk about
basically two issues
in this quite comprehensive field.
One is the law as it
relates to or doesn't relate
to this heartbreaking destruction
in the mid east by ISIS,
the Islamic State, of antiquities.
And does the law -- what
can the law do about that?
The second thing I want to
talk about briefly is the law
and repatriation of items
that are found in museums
and collections around the world.
Both of these are matters of
significant contemporary import.
One of the joys of teaching
this class at Georgetown is
that I can clip the New York
Times and the Wall Street Journal
and the art newspaper every
week and have something to talk
to my students that
is this week's news.
So these are two topics that I think
illustrate the interplay of the law
and the broad issue
of who owns the past.
That ultimately to me is one
of the most challenging issues.
And it's played out in the legal
literature in two elements.
One approach to who owns
the past is what is thought
of as an international approach.
The whole world has a stake
in the culture of the world.
This is not narrowly national.
The second view is a source country,
a country that produced material,
had first dibs to those materials.
And they are not part of the
common heritage of mankind.
This is a tough ongoing issue.
And I would tell you my bias,
having worked on the museum side
of this issue and the collector
and dealer side of this issue --
I have a bias and I
will try to as we go
through here tell you
what's bias and what's fact.
In this debate which
essentially pits the museum
and the collector community
that supports the view
that the world has a right to
antiquities on the one side.
And essentially the archaeological
community and the community
of source countries, this is very
energetic debate that plays out
and has played out in Congress.
Has played out at the
State Department,
plays out in the courts,
plays out in the press.
And plays out very dramatically
in professional organizations.
And my admonition to my students
when we start this course
is be very skeptical
of anything anybody
says in this area.
Because everybody is coming
at this question as to
who owns the past with
a point of view?
I do when I bring in
archaeologists to speak.
They have a point of view.
This is an area to me that one has
to impose healthy skepticism
about anyone's view.
I don't think in this debate
between the museum community
-- let the borders be open.
Let's have free trade in objects.
And an archaeological community
which has a legitimate
opposite view --
I don't think anybody's 100%
right and no one's 100% wrong.
Let's talk about these two issues.
First, the issue of the
return of iconoclasm
with the emergence
of ISIS and Taliban.
And this isn't an abstract question.
You pick up the papers,
particularly in the last two months.
And in one sense your heart
breaks at what's happened at some
of these treasures
in Iraq and Syria.
In Mosul, the tomb of Jonah.
The museums where you had
pictures of ISIS fighters going
in with sledgehammers
breaking down objects.
The Negal Gate where the ISIS
people were taking jackhammers
to these beautiful statues which you
see also happily, safely in the Met.
In Syria, five of six world
heritage sites have been
significantly damaged.
ISIS has just gone into Palmyra
and there is no indication
of specifically the damage that
has already happened there.
But at a moment's notice,
some of the great treasures
of humanity could be destroyed.
Earlier you had the same
issues played out in Kabul
where the Taliban went into
the museum there with hammers
and destroyed non-Islamic items.
And then you had this
totally unbelievable moment
where rocket launchers were
aimed at the majestic statues
of Bamiyan and destroyed.
Statues of Buddha that were 160 and
140 feet high reduced to rubble.
The rationale is that this
is -- my light at least --
this is the rationale of a zealot.
This short quote came from a
transcription of a YouTube --
a transcription of a tape that
described the destruction.
"The ruins that are behind me, they
are idols and statues that people
in the past used to
worship instead of Allah.
The so-called Assyrians and others
looked to gods for war, agriculture
and rain to whom they
offered sacrifices.
The prophet Muhammed took down idols
with his bare hands
when he went into Mecca.
We were ordered by our prophets to
take down idols and destroy them.
When God orders us to remove and
destroy them, it becomes easy for us
and we don't care even if they
care millions of dollars."
I don't think that this is
anything other than the narrow view
of the people wreaking the hammers.
Huge numbers of scholars
and wise commentators
from the Muslim community have
deplored this destruction.
But this is the animating sense
behind what they are doing.
In an acumenital sense they
are doing the Lord's work
by destroying these items.
The question is -- oh, one point.
Nobody in the west can be
overly sanctimonious about this.
We all recall Cromwell going
into Ireland and desecrating
and destroying statues
in Catholic churches.
And we all recall in the
19th century the British
and French armies going into Beijing
and absolutely destroying
the Summer Palace.
So this sense of idolatry
and sanctimony is not
limited to any one group.
But it is an animus, an
impetus that has to be resisted.
This sort of bigotry and absolutism
is the most potent element
in destroying the world's culture.
You know, there are three
issues by my lights.
There are three issues
going on in this fight.
One is the religious impetus.
Second, I think this is
the element of destruction:
is a way to exercise power
and to terrify the populace
that is being overtaken.
One is beheading statues just
as one is beheading individuals.
It is a power play to press
into submission the people
in the territory which
you have overtaken.
The third element is
an economic element.
There has been a lot
of press about the fact
that ISIS has taken small
items, small objects
and put them into the black market.
But I don't think that
the reality is
that that's what's
funding ISIS today.
There's oil, there's money
coming from supporting countries.
We all know that in the commerce,
the black market of antiquities,
the people that got it out of the
ground and the people that gave it
to the first traders get a pittance.
It ain't got big dollars
until it gets
to the west end or
the upper eastside.
So I think though economics
is one rationale.
To me that is not the
critical issue.
Now the question is, what
can the law do about this?
Can it stop the destruction?
The sad reality is that
legal institutions,
international legal
institutions have little power
to stop this destruction.
There are some high-minded
international conventions --
the Hague Convention in 1954,
a UNESCO convention talking
about every nation
has the responsibility
to guard cultural properties.
That is really in this
situation cheap talk.
There is no effective
enforcement mechanism to go in
and stop this destruction.
It ultimately is going to
be, and this is not the kind
of world we would like it to be --
it ultimately is going to be a
matter of who wins the hearts
and minds and the military.
This is going to be a military
and political solution,
not a legal solution.
There are some things that
can be done by the law.
One thing is you can have either an
international or a national embargo
against the import of any of
these items that might be smuggled
out of Afghanistan or Iraq or Syria.
That will only work
if it's international.
With an international market it does
no good to close down the markets
on 57th Street in New York
if there's a thriving market
in the Emirates or in
London or in Paris.
There has to be an
international response.
But there can be some efforts
beyond rhetoric to try to deal
after the fact with the consequences
of the destruction and looting.
And once something is found,
then it's clearly a
candidate to be sent back.
If something is actually
intercepted by customs,
it isn't the easiest thought in
the world where you send it back.
Do you really want to send something
back to Syria at this point?
Or do you hold it?
My preference would be you
make clear this is Syrian
or this is Iraqi and you hold it
for the moment until one's assured
that it can go back to a safe venue.
There are also some
extralegal steps.
And though this is not directed
to the specific geography
of what we're talking about,
this is a step that any nation
which is endangered with
the kind of override
that we've seen in the mid east.
It requires a very careful
inventory of what's in the museum.
That wasn't in the Baghdad
museum when it was looted.
No one could really
figure out what was there.
One needs a process of inventory
and one needs an emergency plan.
Many museums have found their
treasures have been saved
because they've been
taken out of the museum
and sent to some safe place.
It's much like the Louvre
in the second World War.
Where the treasures in the
Louvre were removed and sent
around the French countryside
to safety.
So that part of my discussion
ends on sort of a cautious note.
The law is great in
terms of principle.
The law in this particular
area is not very good in terms
of execution and stopping.
Very quickly I just want to
note about the reparation issue.
I'm sure many of you have read
and followed the great controversy
between the Met and the Getty and
Italy and Greece on some objects
that were bought in
very shady circumstances
by both the Met and the Getty.
Where it was essentially
look the other way
and don't worry too
much about provenance.
These are such beautiful objects,
that justifies their buying.
The basic legal rule, the
basic legal rule as set
down by international
conventions is the nation
where an object is found has control
over it, has ownership over it.
And that's very easy to
define as a matter of policy.
It's not that clear
it's the right rule.
What if the nation where something
is found has no cultural connection
with the object itself?
It's found in the mid east which is
the product of political boundaries
that were designed right
after the first World War.
What if there is no connection
between Turkey and Ephesus?
There's an economic connection,
but there's no cultural connection
between the Ottoman
Empire and the Greek
and Roman treasures in Ephesus.
Does Turkey have first
dibs to those objects?
What happens where you have a county
that doesn't have the capacity
to take care of an
object or has no interest
in taking care of an object?
For a long time the Elgin
marbles debate turned on the issue
of whether there was an
adequate resource in Athens
to take care of the Elgin marbles.
That's all been preempted
now with the construction
of a magnificent 21st,
22nd century museum there.
Third and finally, what
happens where a nation --
should a nation have control and
ownership of an object or objects
which are abhorrent to the
people that are living there?
Do they really have first
dibs on those objects?
My own view on repatriation, and
this is bias, this isn't fact,
is that one ought to approach
questions of repatriation cautiously
and work through the issues
of whether or not the country
where one is sending
it has authority.
The hook has come.
I've got to stop.
I've enjoyed talking to you.
If anybody wants to continuing
arguing or archaeologists want
to punch me in the nose,
we'll be around at lunchtime.
Thank you all very much.
[ Applause ]
>> You've been a tremendously
patient and very fine audience.
And we are now in our third panel
in this extremely interesting
conference on the ancient
and medieval and Byzantine
city of Tyre.
Most people in the United
States at least know of Tyre
through the Biblical narratives.
And so it's only fitting
that we have our last panel
on the Bible and on art.
Now our first speaker is Professor
Mhammed Fantar who is an expert
in western Semitic languages
and Middle East civilizations,
especially Phoenicia and
its colony of Carthage.
He is the former director
general of the National Institute
of Archaeology and Art
of Tunis from 1982-1987.
He is the director of research
at the [French name] and NIMP,
and the director of the Phoenician
Punic Civilization Studies Center
and Libyan Antiquity Center.
Professor Fantar is the
founder of Repal Magazine
that publishes the research
papers of that center.
He is also a professor of
ancient history, archaeology
and religious history at the
Tunis and Zitouna Universities.
I'd like to welcome
Professor Mhammed Fantar
who will be delivering
his lecture [French term]
and the lecture will be translated.
Thank you so much.
[ Speaking French ]
>> It's time for the break.
>> The Phoenician's dream and they
pull us into their dream as well
and it is necessary to dream with
them to enjoy the trip, I think.
[ Speaking French ]
>> I will try to present Tyre to you
in all its importance
in the Mediterranean.
On one side in relation to the
mythology and on the other side
on the archaeological evidence of
the sites in the Mediterranean.
[ Speaking French ]
>> And so before I start
my discourse I would
like to thank this sacred library
for inviting me to do this lecture.
[ Speaking French ]
>> And I mostly would like to thank
Ms. Chalabi for having invited me
to this place and for having
joined the north and the south
and hopefully this joining
will lead to a marriage.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So Tyre and the
mythology during the period
when we were still talking about
Canaanites and not Phoenicians.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So the first evidence
goes back to [French name]
who is the first reference
for the Phoenician presence
and for the Canaanite existence.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So we are discussing
two characters,
two brothers [French names].
And these two brothers managed
to start the first phase
of Phoenician exploration
in the Mediterranean.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So it's the first step
of a Mediterranean ship
travelling from east to west.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So we witness the kidnapping
of a Tyrian princess called Europa
and she is lured and kidnapped by
Zeus the god because of her beauty.
[ Speaking French ]
>> And so I am not going to go
through the entire love story
that is related to
both Europe and Zeus.
But it is a symbol for the joining,
for the connection between the east,
Europa, the Tyrian princess,
and Zeus representing Greece.
So the joining between
east and west.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So the kidnapping of Europa
towards Greece led to a myth
and to a story around
this beautiful princess.
And so it represents this connection
and it is of high importance
to all the upcoming historians.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So Agenor the king
asks his son Cadmous,
the brother of the princess, to
follow her and to look for her
and never to return to
Phoenicia without finding her.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So the word Cadmous actually
presents the oriental man
or the orientalist and the word
comes from the Hebraic Cadum.
And Europa on the other hand
represents Europe, and so the rise
of the sun from the east
and towards the west.
The sunset is very
symbolic of this story.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So this myth, this
legend became the subject
of many ancient historians and
thinkers and even poets such as Vid.
And it even continued
to be a subject
of study towards the late
periods until the 20th century.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So Herodotus in the 5th century
introduced Cadmous to his readers
because he brought the
alphabet to the Greeks.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So the fact that Cadmous left
Phoenicia and went to Greece
on his own and was away
from his fatherland
for a very long time meant that
he adopted a different mentality.
That he became an individual and the
fact that he is a unique individual
and that he created a whole process
by introducing the language
is something extraordinary.
And there is no country without
the effect of one individual.
[ Speaking French ]
[ Applause ]
>> So to translate and make
it as short as possible,
in the Old Testament we have
proof of the importance of Tyre
through the fact that the Old
Testament mentions the temple
of Solomon being built by cedar
wood that was given by David.
And I got mixed up now.
So the wood is coming
all the way from Lebanon
and Tyre has a very important
role in that process.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So the Phoenicians and the
Tyrians have a very important role
as well by travelling from
Tyre to Jerusalem in order
to bring gold from the temple.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So basically they not only
travelled the Middle Eastern coast.
They also travelled towards Spain,
towards Cadiz and towards Carthage.
And they dispersed the
Phoenician tradition.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So as we heard my predecessors
talking about the inscriptions,
the Phoenician inscriptions that are
spread all over the Mediterranean,
we see the similarity between
the Phoenician language
in the first three letters
versus the Greek language
and the first three letters
which are A, B and C. As well
as the same in the Greek version.
So we have an incredible
assimilation
of Phoenician culture
and Phoenician language.
[ Speaking French ]
[ Applause ]
>> So with the Phoenician
travelling they arrived to Carthage.
And Carthage is a very
unique site because it is one
of the first democracies or the
first democracy in the world.
And even Aristotle
himself supposedly said
that he prefers the
political system of Carthage
because it is more
balanced than his own.
[ Speaking French ]
>> So what we find in Carthage is
not only a Phoenician tradition
but a mid eastern tradition
including the traditions that come
from the Mesopotamian world.
And what happened in Carthage proves
that the Middle Eastern world
had its expansion there.
Contrary to what is happening
now with the Islamists
and how they are destroying it.
[ Speaking French ]
>> And so if we are talking
about Mesopotamia he would
like to highlight the evidence
found in Ebla and the site of Ebla
and the tablets that
are found there.
And their importance and the
danger that they are inflicted to,
because the loss of these tablets
would be a loss for humanity.
[ Speaking French ]
[ Applause ]
>> So our next speaker, Dr. Eric
Gubel who's the general director
of the Royal Museums
of Art and History.
He has authored more than 150
contributions to the history,
art history and archaeology of
the Phoenician civilization.
He was the co-editor of the
Studia Phoenicia Collection,
as well as the [French name].
And coordinator of the publication
of Phoenician sculpture
in the Louvre.
As an expert for UNESCO he
repatriated several antiquities
stolen during the civil
war back to Beirut.
He is now coordinating several
international scientific projects,
preparing the edition of the final
reports of the American University
of Beirut excavations led by
Dr. Leila Badre at Tell Kazel.
And more recently Tyre.
Besides a monograph on
Phoenician seals and a second one
on Phoenician art and
how to read it.
And he has found time
nevertheless to come to us to speak.
Please.
>> Dr. Eric Gubel: I would also
like to thank the authorities
of the Library of Congress and of
course Maha for bringing us here.
So thank you all very much.
This lecture is about Kind
Solomon's temple in the Jerusalem,
belonging to the first
temple period.
It was constructed in honor not of
YHWH but in honor of the name of God
in line with the biblical
allegorical tradition.
It's iconology of value stands out
as one of the mightiest metaphors
of the pre-classical world.
On its stern, the Free Masons'
tradition also emphasizes the role
of Hiram, son of the widow, as
the Tyrian king Hiram's tradition.
An architect who eventually
realized one
of the most ambitious building
projects, which lasted seven years.
In doing so he also introduced
the asper masonry technique
of Phoenician architects that
used it as a legacy of the past
since several generations.
Both biblical sources as well
as Judeo-Christian iconography have
yielded lots of representations
of the temple and its
furnishings based merely
on the descriptions
in the book of Kings.
Invariably in the absence,
total absence of actual remains.
So most of them entirely fictitious.
In the present paper I would
like to emphasize the importance
of the archaeological representation
from Hiram's homeland.
It's time to bring this
into the discussion.
Documentation pertaining to the
engineering and designing skills
of his specialized labor.
The [inaudible] no doubt
travelled overland.
The cedar logs had to
be shipped via cabotage
from southern Phoenicia
straight to the biblical land
of Kabul, present day Galilea.
And where 20 settlements were later
granted by Solomon to Hiram of Tyre
as part of his investment
in the project.
In this context the
archeological site
of [foreign name] is a very likely
candidate indeed for the location
with Kabul and Israel
as a halting place
for the cedar beams'
transport to Jerusalem.
This is not only suggested by the
layout of a fort or small sanctuary
in Sidil, but as well by
the presence of cedar logs,
numerous Phoenician oil containers
and several Phoenician artifacts.
Now in order to supply new data
on today's topic we will now
review several items documenting a
plausible reconstruction
of the Jerusalem temple.
These fall into three main groups,
namely architectural elements.
The core differences.
And last but not least, the
temple's cultic furnishings.
I start with, as you can see
on your slide, [inaudible].
So as for the first case example
I refer to the description
of the Solomonic temple windows.
And those of this nearby
palace called the House
of the Forests of Lebanon.
The latter specifies the
[French term] pardon my French.
In other words, the windows to be --
and here we go again
-- [French term].
Etymologically three times.
Which resulted in very confusing
and contradictory translations
of the Old Testament.
But if we are indeed allowed
to translate triple instead
of three times and the description
becomes straightforward reference
to the typical Phoenician window
base with their [inaudible].
Such windows are depicted on dozens
of 9th-8th century Phoenician
ivories, serving as some equivalent
for the Egyptian window
of appearances.
Here however reserved for Phoenician
goddesses of the [foreign word]
like Jezebel about whom Isaiah said,
"Thou hast the forehead of a whore."
She did not have a
hole in her forehead,
but she was wearing these
jewels on her forehead
which characterized
her as a priestess.
A priestess of Baal of course.
So it's fitting that Solomon would
already have windows decorated
in the ancient style of
the Tyre Sidonian kingdom
with straightforward
reference to the cult of Baal.
Poor YHWH.
The false window of a Sidon
[inaudible] -- sorry, no.
I was just calling your
attention to the fact --
you see the plasters have the form
of floral curling, drooping leaves.
A detail also characterized in set
of bronze accessories not only used
as you can see here as
lampstands and torch holders,
but also as braziers
for roasted meet,
libation and incense offerings.
Within the walls of
sanctuaries and banquet halls all
over the Phoenician Mediterranean.
The false window of a Sidon born
deceased buried in part of Cyprus is
of the same type and
although less detailed,
we should add the depiction
of Sidon's windows.
Buildings at the time of
Sennacherib's campaign.
In 1 Kings 6:29 we learn
that Solomon and I quote,
"Decorated the walls of
the house, the temple,
roundabout with carved
figures of cherubim
and palm trees and open flowers."
This description clearly
points to sculpture
and possibly also to
painted freezes.
Since one picture tells
more than a thousand words,
I am showing you here
the typical 9th century,
8th century Phoenician ivory strip.
Which represents exactly
in all details what the
biblical text refers to.
And I will add it to the argument,
when the text further expands
on the open flowers,
the open flowers are
of course the lotus flowers opening
up and used for freezes again
in 9th, 8th century Phoenician art.
There is also Ezekiel who learns us
that the temple's door
jams were decorated
with [inaudible] on either side.
Such capitals nicknamed
proto-aoic are abundantly attested
in many sites south of
Caramel, including Jerusalem.
But also at Ramit-Rahel in
combination with Asper masonry
and triple recessed windows.
And I think I have here some slides.
Considering the fact that the
same combination is attested
in Phoenician realm as attested
here, more precisely at the entrance
of a royal tomb [inaudible], Cyprus.
The often repeated qualification
of the proto-oic capital
as a typical Israelite invention
can no longer be sustained.
You all remember of
course from the book
of Kings the detailed description of
the seraphim whose wings overlapped.
These of course are the
typical winged sphinxes used
in Phoenician cabinet making.
And a nice example is of course
the coffin of Hiram king of Byblos.
Who reused a relieved sarcophagus of
the 12th century BC around 1000 BC.
His forefather is represented
on the throne which is flanked
by the two winged sphinxes who
were actually the [inaudible]
of the cherubim of
the Solomonic temple.
Now also place your attention for --
oh no, I can't point
this out to you.
No, it's on the touch screen.
Sorry. On the footstool,
the footstool.
If you have a look at the
footstool you will say, "Hey,
this resembles these
proto-ioc capitals."
For yes indeed, there
is another prototype
of what we find some generations
later in the Solomonic temple
because it was constructed
by a Phoenician architect.
And then we also have
this tripod table
and this tripod table was still used
in the third temple of Jerusalem.
And now we are in the
1st century BCE.
This is a [inaudible] coinage
of [Foreign name] the Great
and you see a tripod table.
A typical Phoenician invention
which was still connected
with all kinds of temple
furnishings.
And already in the early 1st
millennium BCE, as can be seen
on these pieces, inspired
on the Phoenician prototype.
The sphinx throne, the cherubim
throne was always associated
with a footstool and a tripod.
And this gives us the origin
of a type of cultic item used
through that 1st millennium
by Phoenician artists
as a typical Phoenician.
And now we are going to
present another cultic item
which is associated with the
temple, namely the cupboards.
Cut boards.
Here we have a tiny ivory
plaque from 9th century BCE,
which can be perfectly well dated
because of the form of the black
on red juglet which is
represented at the top of it.
Classical Egyptian type.
On the right you have
the Egyptian prototype.
Well, this type of
cupboard, which was used
to chest libation vases
used for ritual libations,
also figures on one of the reliefs
of [inaudible] around 700 BC.
[Inaudible] already
Phoenician inscriptions.
It was indeed a site in Phoenicia
of the very strong
Phoenician influence.
So here we have this cupboard.
And what is funny about cupboard
is that it is placed upside down.
You see the round, the
whole round segment
which actually should
be the roof of a tent,
like the tent of the tabernacle.
It's placed upside down.
One might think that
this is due to the hands
of an inexperience sculptor,
were it not that on the theory
of [inaudible] in the eastern delta.
A priest, an officiating
priest, is standing on a cupboard
of exactly the same type and
it's reversed once again.
[French term] as we say in French.
So this means that we are dealing
here with a Phoenician reproduction
of an Egyptian cupboard which
is datable to roughly 700 BC.
And the question is if cupboards
of this type were already
used in the temple.
And here I'm going
to skip a chapter.
Not to raise any suspicion,
just know that the last part will be
a bit more what was in the cupboard.
Well what was in the cupboard
was, as I told you already,
a set of vessels used for
liquid offerings for libations.
And the prototype was
the Egyptian situla.
My colleague and good friend,
the Syrian archaeologist
[Foreign name] just found a series
of the situlae during
his excavations at Amrit.
And I was asked to
prepare a publication.
They were found together with
small amulets showing a priest
in the middle of a libation.
It always goes together in
the 7th, 6th century BC --
situlae and these Egyptian bronzes.
The same set was found in
Ashkelon which is normal
because our friend Patrick McGovern
showed us the town with shipwrecks.
These are saucer jars from Tyre
which they were on the road
for Ashkelon and not
the other way around.
The biggest such cluster of
situlae was found at Memphis, Egypt.
More precisely in the
necropolis of the sacred animals.
And this necropolis was situated
in the shadow of the temple of Fah.
And this brings us to
Herodotus who described
at this very spot near the temple of
Hapshepsut, the camp of the Tyrians.
Thus for the first time we
have proof of the presence
of these Phoenician
artists in Memphis.
If we look at some of these situlae,
certain details are
completely un-Egyptian,
such as a scarab with
two pairs of wings.
You have to look for them, but if
you look for them you find them.
We know already of three situlae
with Phoenician inscriptions
from the 7th, 6th century BC.
The one in the Louvre
alas un-deciphered as yet.
This brings us to another of the
context [inaudible] of the temple.
The sea of bronzes.
Sources agree upon
the fact that the sea
of bronzes is actually a reference
to the wheeled carts
of the late bronze age.
Most of them produced in Cyprus,
but other ones in the [inaudible].
And here I'm showing you an
example just to make a point.
In Phoenician mints, and I'll
show you the late 9th century seal
of Shina.
Here we have a gold statue,
and if you look closely you see
that the god is standing with
his feet on a wheeled cart.
And this brings us to
a kind of [inaudible].
We speak of a tabernacle.
Looking around during
ceremonies in Sidon
on local coinage of the period.
And you see that the top
of the [inaudible] you have
these four palm branches.
If you go to the Shina
cemetery in Tyre
for example during the age people
also placed these four palm branches
on the graves of their deceased.
And actually such real [inaudible]
have been excavated at Beirut
and other places in the near east.
A couple of months ago, almost
a year ago, there were a couple
of shrines [inaudible] in Israel.
And were immediately
described as the prototypes
of the temple of Jerusalem.
You can actually see a little model
reproduced or enlarged to the right.
Shows for the first time a very
important element of the temple
of Jerusalem upon which I am
going to end this presentation.
Namely the curtain.
The temple's veil.
A kind of a barrier which was
hiding the most sacred place,
the innermost holy of
holies in the temple.
I still have 10 minutes, perfect.
Oh, I have five minutes?
I have to rush a bit.
What you see here is -- well
the curtain you don't see
because it's wrapped around a
rail upon which it was hung.
Okay, wrapped around.
That is a very, very, very simple
way of getting rid of your curtain.
Then you just let it down.
And Maha of course recognizes one
of the shops in the site of Tyre,
more precisely in the
Sidonian harbor.
Okay, this is the idea, the curtain.
Please, please, please follow me.
Although tablets, cuneiform
tablets from 13th century BC,
there is question about
the violation of something
and about people getting
the asylum right
because they touched the
veil of the temple of Sidon.
This is the very first time that
we hear about the asylum right
and a veil in the temple.
A prefiguration of the veil
in the temple of Jerusalem.
And once again we're in Phoenicia,
in what was to become the
Tyre Sidonian kingdom.
Now I cannot show you a photograph
at the end of this expose
of the temple of Jerusalem.
In that case I would be a
National Geographic billionaire.
But I can show you a document,
a contemporary document,
contemporary with the temple.
Which is as good as the
best photo will ever get.
A Phoenician bull.
And the Phoenician
bull which represents
by four times not a zoo
with exotic animals.
But the structure of the
innermost of the Jerusalem temple
with its veil as described.
And now going back to
my text, 2 Chronicles 3.
What we are looking at is a
veil embroidered with figures
of falcon-headed winged sphinxes.
The cherubim of 2 Chronicles 3.
Fixed by means of what you
see here on the drawings.
Fixed by means of a
trail-less fringe with tassels
in the form of pomegranates.
Pomegranates also adorned the robes
of the priests officiating
in the Jerusalem temple.
And once again this is preceded
by the outfit of priests in Ugarit
where even the mold for the
gold pomegranates has been found
in the course of the excavations.
And in 2 Chronicles 14 it is said,
"He, Solomon, made interwoven chains
and put them on top of the pillars."
So forget all about these
representations of Jakan and Baals
in the temple of Solomon.
There is no question of capitals
in the form of the pomegranates.
Here the pomegranates are
here at the top of the curtain
which represents these
cherubim as I showed you,
as I pointed out on this slide.
Now finally, as a special
present for Maha,
three more minutes, Mr. President.
As a final present, a couple
of years ago the Spanish excavation
brought to light this model
of a shrine and everyone thought
that, what could this possibly be?
Well, now that I told you about
the temple, about the importance
of the temple and the temple's
veil and about the tradition,
the Phoenician tradition of veils,
embroidered veils in the temple,
what if I showed you this
model as a model of temple
with a temple veil blowing
out of the inner space?
And if you don't believe me, I
have you by a recitation, quoting.
This has everything to do with
the lost temple, the third temple.
The letter of Istaios,
one of these said --
and I cannot translate
this into English
because the French is so beautiful.
So you will ask for some of
your colleagues afterwards.
[ Speaking French ]
The veil of the temple.
So much for the temple.
So much for the song
of the widow or Hiram.
For the first time now illustrated
with archaeological
documents from the homeland.
And this is something we
should have done a generation
or two generations ago.
Because we were given a pair of
ears, we were given a pair of eyes.
And in the best of cases
also, like my compatriots,
[inaudible] called
the gray little cells.
Let's use them.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> I have to say a
personal note about how all
of these speakers are taking me
back to graduate school days.
And people like Javier Texador
and Morton Smith talking
about these same sites.
Thank you for opening,
reopening my eyes on this.
We are coming to the end
of this marvelous symposium
with a very intriguing
speech if I may say so.
A topic that is only coming into
the fore the last decade or two.
And that would be by Mrs. Rodi
Kratsa who was born and brought
up on the Island of
Zakynthos, Greece.
She studied sociology at the
University of Geneva in Switzerland.
Her post-graduate studies
followed at the Institute
of European Studies at
that same university.
She has riche experience and
long tenure in European politics,
having acquired important
high-level positions as a member
of the European parliament
and vice president.
She handled a significant portfolio
such as the conciliation
procedure with other institutions.
The EP communication
information policy,
and the Euro-Mediterranean
relations.
She represented the European
parliament in high level summits
and ministerial conferences
worldwide.
She is a member of the EP,
European parliament, obviously.
Committees on economic and
monetary affairs, employment
and social affairs,
transport, budgetary control
and women's rights
and gender equality.
With important initiatives
in rich parliamentary work.
In parallel, Mrs. Kratsa
has always been very active
at international level.
She has worked systematically
for the deepening
of European Union relations with
significant areas of the world,
especially the Caucuses region, the
south shore of the Mediterranean,
the gulf area countries
and Latin America.
She participates in major
initiatives for peace
in the Middle East and has taken an
active role in protecting the rights
of Christians and religious
minorities
where there is discrimination
and violence as well
as the protection of
the Jordan River.
She is an ardent advocate
of the Civil Society
and actively participates
in various organizations
within Greece and beyond.
Elected municipal council of
Athens, 1998, as she is president
of the International Association for
the Promotion of Women of Europe,
Women of Europe Award, AIPFE.
Board member at the European
Center of Culture Geneva.
Member of the honorary
committee of the Tyre Foundation.
A board member
of the Euro-Mediterranean
University of Fes, Morocco.
Mrs. Kratsa has been honored by
heads of state, religious leaders
and international bodies.
She is an honorary doctor
of two fine universities.
She is also one of
the four laureates
of the Elissa Dido Award for 2014.
And this afternoon she
finishes the conference
by addressing Elissa Dido.
Mediterranean women.
Mrs. Kratsa.
[ Applause ]
>> Rodi Kratsa: Thank you for
your kind and generous words.
Ladies and gentlemen, let me
at first thank you once again
for your continuous
presence and attention.
Perhaps some people will
wonder why is this cultural
and historical symposium ending
on an issue regarding
women in the Mediterranean?
I believe that the
organizers and the designers
of the program had the correct
thought and choice with this issue,
which has value both
historical and contemporary.
It would be a deficient presentation
of Tyre as a center for culture
for the Phoenicians and
of the Mediterranean
and if we do not mention the women
figures which played a vital role.
Homer mentions that women of the
Phoenicians were fantastic warriors
and supplied the merchants
throughout the Mediterranean
with their fabric, which
were a symbol of the culture
of the Phoenicians
particularly in purple color.
But Tyre also gave to the world
figures of women which played a role
in genealogies and alliances
which determined the ancient world
and which continue to this day.
I mentioned at first Europe.
A mythological but fatal figure
as mentioned by Professor Fantar.
As he said, the god Zeus to
Europa to arrive in Crete
where they had children
like king Minos,
founder of the Minolian
civilization.
And as he also said,
the myth continues.
Cadmous, Europa's brother, came
to Greece searching for her.
And just I would like to add
that during his stay he
built a city, Thebes.
Which existed till today, which
is about an hour from Athens.
Ladies and gentlemen, the
Phoenician princess Europa came
from the orient, gave
her name of course
to the continent which welcomed her.
And I would like to say
that the myth of adoption
of Europa symbolized the
globalized world of that period.
And throughout time, the close
relations of the European countries
and the European Union today
with the countries from the south
and base of the Mediterranean.
The institutional framework of
these relations is called today
Euro-Mediterranean partnership
and constitutes the union
for the Mediterranean.
I come now to the main
subject, Princess Elissa
of Venetia is associated
with the myth of the creation
of Carthage in today's Tunisia.
The myth is a mix of historical
evidence for the environment
of Phoenicia, and with
literary evidence
from the Hellenic and Roman world.
In the epic work of Vergil, Elissa
is mentioned by the name Dido.
The center person, Elissa, Dido
for the Romans, and Didon coming
from the barbaric tradition
for the Tunisians.
She incorporates the courage, the
initiative, the determination,
the creativity and the fidelity.
Displays from Venetia
due to domestic disputes
which deprives the life
of her [inaudible],
she managed to take those faithful
with her as well as young women
from Cyprus towards Tunisia.
She builds Carthage in contradiction
with the domestic powers.
She sacrificed herself to
[inaudible] who had lost life.
Building on the symbolic reference
of this, a legendary area,
Tyre Foundation launched in
corporation with Med 21 the program
of the Institute for Prize
related to Mediterranean Legacy.
And Didon goes outward off Carthage,
who causes Tunisian women actions
in the world with the name
Elissa Dido for the promotion
of women condition
in the Mediterranean.
It will be awarded every year
to two distinguished ladies.
One for the north shore and
one for the south shore.
Winners are selected based on a
significant contribution they made
to promote principles and values
and complete achievements
in all sector areas.
Culture, economics, education,
politics and the promotion
of the status of women and equality.
An important condition of the award
is the promotion of cooperation
with the north and the
south of the Mediterranean.
Linking people and actions.
The award will be attributed
every year during the festivities
of the League of Canaanite,
Phoenician and Punic Cities.
[ Inaudible ]
There has already been the
first award ceremony in Athens,
the previous October at
the Acropolis Museum.
I have the honor to be one of the
Laureates for this first edition,
due to the long-term
advocation of the promotion
of the Euro-Mediterranean
relations and the role of women.
The other Laureates, which were
four in total, only for the case
of the first edition are
Lady Cochrane Yvonne Shoushak
from Lebanon.
Awarded in recognition of her
commitment to the protection
of the legacy of the
Lebanese cultural heritage
across different sectors,
architecture, art, environment.
The second one is Cherifa Kheddar
from Algeria in recognition
of her commitment to promote human
rights, in particular the rights
of the victims of violence.
And Souhair Belhassen from
Tunisia in recognition of her fight
for the rights of men and
women in international level.
The importance of this award is
great because it serves many goals.
It reminds us of the
role of women in history,
something that historians
often forget.
It gives visibility and
leadership to the work of women
in the modern society,
something which the mass media,
the political parties and the
academic community also forgets.
It brings to the surface women
as role models and as examples
to follow towards the encouragement
for action and participation.
Not only for other women,
but for the society.
The Elissa Didon Prize
as a directive method emphasizes the
human diversity, the equal rights
and opportunities between men and
women are occurring everywhere
and especially around
the Mediterranean.
The Mediterranean with its countries
and its people is not
a uniform zone.
At some places women suffer from
unemployment and the degradation
of their standard of living
such as in the north shore
as the result of an economic crisis.
Along the south shore,
besides economic problems women
are continuing to suffer violence
and oppression from fundamentalists.
It is important that we promote
on the international level
these problems and issues.
But also that we all know the
exceptional women giving a voice
and support to the vulnerable women.
And who succeed in spite
of the difficulties
and make important work
advancing the society.
And the encouragement of
peace, cooperation and justice.
The Tyre Foundation also has
a goal to give the opportunity
to the laureates of the prize to
meet each other and create networks
of cooperation and solidarity.
For the success of this goal,
your support is valuable.
Initially, your participation in the
giving of the award Elissa Didon,
and other activities,
is so that you can honor
and meet these women
and know their work.
You can also support the effort of
the Tyre foundation in this field
through donations, through the
programs of research centers,
foundations and international
organizations.
The Congress which
is hosting us today,
as well as the American Civil
Society supports with passion
and generosity the
respect of human rights
and especially women's rights.
We have ascertained these past
few years how important education,
justice, equal opportunities
and the advancement of women are
in all countries everywhere,
even those that are far.
So we can have peace
and prosperity globally
and in our societies,
in each society.
In conclusion, ladies and
gentlemen, I would like to thank you
and express my belief that we
will have many opportunities
for collaboration in supporting the
Tyre Foundation issues and goals
for the promotion of women.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> I want to thank each one of the
panelists for a fitting conclusion
to this wonderful conference.
Thank you for your patience
and your participation.
There will be tours I
understand after this.
And at the moment I would like
to finish by inviting the chief
of the African and Middle Eastern
division, an energetic cosponsor
of this conference,
Dr. Mary-Jane Deeb.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: So I just want
to thank you all for being here.
It's so exciting to see you,
to have this special program.
I hope that we will continue working
on ancient cities that have shared
with us and the basis of our
civilization as we know it today.
Just a word of thanks.
Thanks to the participants.
You have all been absolutely
fabulous.
Thank you, Maha, for having
made this event possible.
Thank you for your team.
Thank you for everyone who has come
hear from Tunisia, from France,
from Belgium, from Spain, from
Lebanon and from around the world
to be part of this very
special event today.
So thank you all.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.